Bobby Kelly got us four,
three,
two,
one.
Can you talk about that on there and no?
Yeah.
It doesn't say he got us his knives bed.
We weren't bushwhacking.
Oh.
Uh,
and he got this one guy was like,
I want to make you guys not have suited me.
Joe.
Listen,
Robert Kelly like custom knives.
Knives,
Huh?
Yeah.
Machete type knife to chop up some wood.
Oh fuck it.
We're doing camping,
hiking and then hiking like four hours to a campsite.
Really loves fly fishing.
Right.
Isn't he a big fly Fisher?
Yeah.
He maybe he likes doing shit that he,
his body shouldn't allow him to do.
Um,
it's crazy.
When you was skinny.
That's nuts.
I see that video,
that picture of him,
that headshot the comedy cellar.
I'm like,
that's that guy dude.
He was like my size.
He was like a normal sized person.
It's nuts to me.
It is nuts.
Yeah.
When I met him,
we were working together and he lived in,
um,
a home with a special needs kids and um,
he would like take care of them.
Oh,
that was,
he was,
uh,
like a,
like a counselor or some sort of a teacher or something like with special needs
kids and um,
he was totally normal size.
Wow.
Like you would see him like,
uh,
let me compare him to somebody.
He's a fat fuck now.
I haven't seen him in a long time.
I mean I let me just trash him for a minute about his big overweight.
I'm sad because I really liked that guy.
He's a sweetheart.
Yeah.
Well enjoy them while you can.
He has a kid too,
right?
Yeah.
As a kid.
Great.
Good.
Well why is he allowing himself to eat himself to death?
Okay.
Well I think a little bit in the addict's mind,
you don't really have it.
You're not really an addict.
You've got,
it's like the replacement thing is real.
You gotta replace one with the other.
What was his attic before?
We think coke and,
and um,
then booze.
Yeah,
that's a thing,
man.
That's a real thing.
That's it out every time.
He tries to get in shape and think does a month and then like it just falls off
a day.
And then just keeps falling off.
He's fatter than ever now.
Yeah.
I saw a photo from that cruise at Burt went on with them and I was like,
Oh God.
Yeah.
They couldn't let him go anywhere but the middle of the boat.
Otherwise,
who would like to,
that's crazy.
Sharks and shit,
which I feel like I'm this side,
this side,
Bobby,
we have a chance to eat all those.
Well,
you can't be on a boat with those fucking buffets to man,
those buffets are brutal.
I gained 12 pounds in a week on the joker's cruise last year.
I believe it.
Oh yeah.
Buffets or rough man.
Uh,
we,
uh,
last time I was in Vegas,
I ate that at the buffet and they're great.
You just hate crepes.
All kinds of shit.
I should never eat.
Oh,
go for thirds.
A small portion,
fried chicken and waffles and it's like your friends go,
your friends go,
uh,
you want to eat.
I'm like,
no,
I just say like four hours ago.
Like what?
Come sit with us.
We're like,
okay,
I saw some fries.
I'll go get it.
Some cupcakes,
some cupcakes.
How rich you get the free,
it's free.
You can just take whatever you'd have to open your,
well,
it's such an easy process right there.
I could just grab it,
do the best.
Is these fucking Filipino and like these immigrant type like employees that are
clear,
are you guys done with this?
And like,
Oh yeah,
I'm done.
They're like,
are you kidding me?
This could feed my whole village,
which you're throwing away.
It's like keep that smile on their face.
When you find out the real statistics of like how much people make in certain
countries,
you know like I was reading something about how much people look at the average
salary of a person who lives in Thailand.
It's like a thousand dollars a month did.
I was on a bus from Indonesia to East Timor to cross a land border and some guy
was talking about how much people make and I told them,
it's like,
wait,
what?
I'm like have a cost of living is way higher.
And he's like,
oh that's great.
I should have a $50 bill.
He was like lost his mind.
Wow.
How many,
how many Cha Cha,
I forgot how,
what their currency is,
how many is this worth?
And I told him,
he's like,
why?
Yeah,
I think I'm wrong to about a thousand dollars a month.
They make those high.
It's possible.
It might be like one quarter of that.
A lot of them also don't use currency that much.
They're like,
yeah,
we farm,
we trade with our neighbor milk.
I mean like we don't need currency.
Did we took these lessons on how to,
how to grow,
how to like,
uh,
take rice,
plant it and like they take you through the whole steps in Thailand,
they give you the outfits and everything needed.
All the people that farm rice where,
but you realize like before industrialized agriculture,
what a process it was to actually get rice.
Like fuck that.
It is a giant process.
It's crazy how much work is involved.
Yeah.
You see them up to their fucking wasted water.
I saw a dead dog in a rice patty wants to face down.
They're still serving that rise,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
They're not going to waste that rice.
Do you think they wash it off at all or like maybe
you're going to put dead dog on it anyway.
Yeah.
All cause it's on cook console wrong.
Well the thing about the rices,
like I thought that at least when you get the rice you'd just get the rice off
the plant and then you could boil it and need it.
No,
no.
It's like a husk and you've got to beat it down and break it open and then the
actual rice is underneath it.
Oh,
I'm just finding this about weed.
I thought you'd just pick weed off a planet,
smoke it and like,
no,
you've got to curate and dry and cure it.
You know it's the worst female weed is which one?
Right.
Oh right.
But male and female,
we'd get together and they,
if the mail we'd and the female we'd get together,
it ruins the weed.
Like kind of like kind of like real life.
Kind of like real life.
Yeah,
man.
Ruined everything.
I didn't know that.
Uh,
that w that plants like,
I don't know Jack Shit about horticulture or agriculture,
but they,
they breed like a male.
And a female version of these plants.
I was like,
what?
Like some guy was it grow?
It was trying to explain it to me like how they isolate the female plants.
Like go wait a minute.
What?
Pete knows a lot about it.
Of course he does,
but like,
yeah,
it's like none of this makes sense.
What are you talking about?
Plant girl talking about plants you're on.
Yeah.
No,
their plants.
They don't have a giant as you fucking idiot.
Idiot.
Hey guys,
this thing I'd never researched.
I know way more about this guy who lives in life and it looked into it.
I was stunned.
I was like,
there's a male version of female version of a fucking plant.
What real dude?
I,
the more I've researched plants because uh,
I had on this guy who's fascinating man.
You should really,
if you can get them on your podcast,
he,
Paul Stamets.
Yeah,
I heard him on NPR.
Oh,
he should have mine.
I'll hook you guys up.
Okay.
You would love it.
Especially when he finds out that you invented a shrimp fest.
You know,
he would love you.
But,
um,
when he was explaining to me the system through which plants exchange nutrients
and information with fun guy and that fun guy.
Yeah.
Fun Guy actually supply these plants with certain nutrients and they,
they,
there's like an information network of these mycelium that's underneath the
ground.
That's how it is.
I've heard about this how like what trees will do is communicate with each other
work.
When she was dying,
they'll send nutrients to the other,
I guess through my ceiling is the context dude.
It's fucking bananas.
Yeah.
And it all underneath the ground,
underneath the ground is this whole almost like information exchanging network
of fungi.
Wow.
I like this one.
Need to help.
Yeah,
man.
They,
they know when others need more resources,
they have like a socialist network of allocation of resources.
It's fucking crazy.
Well and,
and they communicate with each other and when they're being eaten,
please help me.
They know,
they know that other ones are being eaten and they'll change their flavor
profile.
They're actually,
they actually make their polar leaves more bitter to avoid predation.
Someone's here eating.
I'm fucking put up your defenses.
It's so cool that you can have the sound of caterpillars chewing leaves.
You could play it like on a recording next to a plant and that plant will change
it's flavor profile.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
They become so disgusting that giraffes won't eat them and they'll starve to
death because it's gross.
Disgusting.
They're trying to get kids not to get their nails painted with that stuff that
tastes gross.
No.
Did they do that stupid kids and her nails the fucking kids to eat their boogers
and you're like,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
You eat your boogers all the time with them.
When he got to do with them,
throw away trash receptacle for boogers.
God,
you put them in a tissue and you'd be gone with them.
We don't eat your boogers.
You savage Rhonda boogers.
Wow.
Okay.
You do what you gotta do?
I have one of these Jerry shifts.
I,
this would actually my house.
Oh,
nice.
I got one of your,
uh,
crazy mushroom shirts.
Which tour was that from?
Do Mushrooms tour?
Uh,
I think it was two specials ago.
Not the last year.
Was that one.
And then there was another one with you or your tongue open with,
with uh,
uh,
2012.
That's the 2012 shirts.
That's the coolest shirt.
I might not bring this back since I fucked up and didn't do a shirt this year.
She's bring that back just to sell it.
You should just sell it period.
It's a cool one.
Yeah.
I liked the idea of going like,
cause cause I'm iron maiden had that with like a shirt per year.
You can show it off at the next iron man concert.
But yeah,
I mean if you had to be at that concert,
otherwise you're fucked.
That's the one I got that one in the hot black chick on top.
Ted Park did that.
That's like I did the Korean Zombie shirt.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Damn.
He's good.
He is good.
That's a great fucking shirt man.
Yeah.
And your eyes sufficiently whacked out and people are like why is Mark Marin and
your shirt
or a the guy from grateful dead matches.
Mark Baron went the other way,
super drugged out,
gave up on sobriety and just went all mushrooms.
He's totally the other way as a variety going mark.
Oh good.
You should ask.
I failed to put this on your doors.
I realize,
what the fuck am I doing?
Avoiding all the best parts of life.
Yeah,
that's,
that's teaching me this sober October thing is teaching me a lot.
My bartender last night I went to O'neill's wedding,
I don't knows what her and I was like,
do you have any it's out of brewery.
Right.
And uh,
I was like,
do you have any non alcoholic beer?
Like I was saying like it helps us social cause socially it's fuck everyone's
drinking,
you know?
Um,
and he goes,
yeah,
he goes sober October.
And I'm like,
yeah,
but he didn't,
he didn't know a lot of people know this contest,
but he was just like,
I'm doing it too.
Did you know about it before last year?
Because we were going to do it earlier or later.
But then Burt had an Australia thing.
I'm like,
there's no way you're doing in Australia.
You can't be sober in Australia and you can't be sober for the joker's cruise.
And that was November,
I think first week in November or something,
and so we'd like just settled on October,
so we just stumbled upon it and other people have been doing it for years
apparently.
How long sober October have been going on for a long time.
Yeah.
Jamie says long time off Mike,
because he doesn't realize we're podcast share a while.
Oh,
who's that?
that sounds like Austin's,
yeah,
it's apparently been going on for a long time ago.
I was doing it completely lucked into it,
dude.
Somebody,
I was at the jets game,
somebody sent me a beer and I was like,
what?
And then I turned and there's a,
I was like,
oh,
I can't,
and the was like,
I was trying to catch you.
That's I'm doing for this dance.
Diaz things,
births,
drinking.
He does.
Wow.
Yeah.
Really?
It was,
I think birch drinking.
He goes,
I saw him the other day.
Look guilty.
He ducked his head down,
wasn't looking at me.
I think he's drunk and Joe Rogan.
Oh,
I've wanted to so bad.
I actually needed a break this time I went to Sushi.
I told you I went to Sushi and when was,
I was like,
Oh yeah,
get a nice cool.
That'll be,
fuck.
It's October.
God dammit.
It's like earaches.
You realize now it's not just casually drinking that there's moments where booze
really does go well with an experienced stake in a nice glass of red wine.
Yes.
November 5th son,
we're going off.
If I'm a fifth we're going off.
That's what I'm going to do.
The recap podcast.
We're all going off,
so Ari and I have been battling for first place recently until today when
Thompson tourists snuck in a second place with his 400 plus points today.
That really puts a pressure on me.
It really hurt me to not,
I finally joined a gym because of this.
I have two blankets,
a small gym,
but it's like right near my seven minute walk from my apartment so I can pass on
the way home from the seller.
I can get a workout in right then if I want.
That's good.
Yeah.
It's 24 hours as far as weekdays,
so it's a crazy fucking life.
There's a crazy life in New York too.
Everything's 24 there's so many 24 hour things.
Restaurants,
pool halls.
Yeah.
I passed by that place.
We went a bunch of times.
Which place?
All the time.
Sudan.
Amsterdam.
Yeah.
That's always there.
That plays the only up until two.
Oh really?
Yeah,
but it's still pretty late.
There's a few real sketchy joints there.
24 hours.
But if you go in there,
you'll get a bunch of creeps at want to gamble with you.
It looks like they're cause good.
I'm just trying to hit some balls,
trying to take my mind off things.
They're cracked out and trying to hustle.
This is very little of that anymore though.
It's New York.
It's cleaned up for the worst or the better.
I mean hustling pool,
hustling.
It's chance cause just kind of died.
Really?
Yeah.
So it was like pools dead.
They have like leagues now.
Yeah.
You know?
It's like,
well,
I mean that's good.
I'm just happy if people play.
It's a fun thing to play,
but it's dead in terms of like the way it used to be in Manhattan where there
was just gambling everywhere.
You don't have to turn of the century.
There was a thousand pool halls in New York City.
What?
Yeah,
19 hundreds the early 19 hundreds did you ever see the,
the,
the pool tables like outside in Thailand when you were there?
No,
I didn't,
but I here in the Philippines.
It's crazy.
Yeah,
and it's just like,
there'll be some like an awning or something or just want to set up kind of like
people who go tailgating in those kinds of tents and they'll be under that and
you can just pull over and be like complete and there'll be like white guy for
sure.
Let's play.
No gambling.
Just like having a fun time.
Really?
Oh yeah.
I saw one in Chiang Mai.
In that downtown marketplace area.
Yeah,
I saw one.
How Fun was that?
Fucking Thai kickboxing.
I'm pretty fun.
Thai fights.
So cool.
And they played the most,
the instrument,
right?
How Fun.
Fun Is that?
Yeah,
it's pretty wild.
I've been to those out here where they play it,
but Americans get real bored with the y crew.
The dance.
They do.
Yeah.
They do a dance for their,
for their own Dojo.
Yeah.
Well they do.
Everybody does it and there's a real logic behind it.
The logic is that you warm up and that you really relax yourself.
You're kind of performing in front of all these dance moves and also people are
staring at you.
So it kind of wears off your nerves.
There's a reality to that.
It,
it's actually really wise,
you know,
and you lose,
you limber up your body to like,
a lot of the stuff they're doing is they're getting down on one knee like a
lunge and they're bouncing a little bit and so their limb bring up their body
and then on top of that they're actually doing this dance in front of all these
people and it calms the nerves a little bit.
Wow.
Yeah.
John Fixed,
we're always talking about that.
About like the idea of people watching you.
It's actually a big thing.
And the UFC is like a bigger people watching you it then.
Oh yeah.
Anywhere else.
It's a tougher people watching you.
It's fucking hot.
I mean people watching you and you shoot a free throw,
you know?
Good Dude.
Bunch of people watch it.
Oh fuck.
Here we go.
That's real.
Even if it's just like five of your friends.
Yeah.
Pressure.
The pressure's and fucking real man.
I mean,
that's what everybody's most terrified about what we do.
Public speaking.
I had somebody that we were giving a talk on Shakespeare's home.
It was a group project.
We each had to write one paragraph.
We wrote three paragraphs at each one of us read one,
so I think I read mine,
just reading it off a paper.
It was paying attention.
The next day was like,
and then later Shakespeare had the off time
and was just looking at her like,
what the fuck?
And the teacher was like,
okay,
okay.
It's all right.
Let's start.
Let's start with always on wheels route.
And I was like,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
It's a phrase he is waiting.
It was a standup,
but like to make any sense,
I used to panic when I would talk to bank towers.
What?
Yeah.
I used to go to a bank till I get super nervous right before I'd have to talk to
a bank teller.
Why?
I Dunno.
It's no reason for it.
When I was a kid I've,
I really felt like a loser.
I really did.
I had like serious low self esteem issues up until like high school you up until
martial arts.
And then once I started doing martial arts and getting really good at it and
then teaching,
it kind of calmed me down experience and then it kind of like,
was it,
believe it or not,
almost like a natural path to stand up.
But I remember before that being very awkward talking to people like very
nervous talking to people I didn't know,
you know,
just didn't,
didn't feel like I still get that where I'm like,
I don't know how to talk.
Yeah.
Just trying to draw.
I don't know how to talk to.
Yeah,
I know.
Right.
Especially if it's an odd thing and you know what was worse when I know you too
and ask your questions are so broad.
What's Joey Diaz like?
Oh boy.
Yeah,
that's,
that's hard.
He met a good to ask you a question.
Uh,
which I do for a living,
uh,
trying to get my shit together.
Okay.
Fire,
fire truck operator.
Yeah.
You should make ladders.
Like what?
I don't know anything about you.
What are you talking about?
You know you used to be a carpenter but I don't want to do it anymore.
Okay.
I'm thinking I'm doing standup.
Should I do it like definitely no,
go for it.
How would you want I say go for it.
Sure.
I guess if you want to do it,
do it.
Yeah.
Like everything is like that,
but if it doesn't work out,
don't get mad at me.
I'm like,
no,
I'm not being responsible for this.
Oh,
you told me to become a fight or no,
I'm all fucked up.
He told me to do what you do too.
I've got a broken arm now,
bro.
Who's going to fix this?
Huh?
You Bro.
That's the answer.
You motherfucker fix that shit.
Don't get it fixed.
Yeah.
I was talking to a friend of mine who,
uh,
I want to name his name cause he got a pretty significant injury and um,
we were talking about,
uh,
his injury and it's fucking bad man.
You know,
he needs surgery and he,
his bone is changing shape because of arthritis.
It's building up in his joint.
I'm like,
Oh fuck.
And he's a young guy and he just makes you realize like the fucking punishment
these guys are putting on their body.
And that's like totally below the surface that people don't know it's behind the
curtain.
No one knows about it.
And they've got like these devastating injuries at,
they're fighting off and then competing against worldclass fighters with
injuries.
He's torn ligaments and Tony Ferguson,
he's like,
he doesn't look comfortable on that leg.
No.
And he's like,
yeah,
it wasn't,
you know what?
He went six months from catastrophic knee injury where the bone literally
separated from the ligament.
The ligament tore off the boat.
You ever see the,
the,
the picture of his surgery?
Oh,
Jayman push it up,
pull that shit up.
Chain.
It's a crazy surgery because it's,
I'm not exaggerating,
it might be a 12 inch scar.
It's enormous.
It's like that big and it's all jagged and shit and it's just,
he ripped it apart.
They had an open amount of 12 months,
not even six months.
Six months.
I mean,
yeah.
Insane.
I don't understand how that,
that guy doesn't clearly get the title shot.
He does.
We should talk about that.
Look at that.
Wow.
That's crazy.
And the thing is that was just from a trip he just tripped was fucking bananas.
Yeah.
What's the second image,
Jeremy?
Oh,
the other side.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
The um,
the extent of that injury.
The,
the fact that he came back in six months and what's really interesting is he
came back in six months.
He didn't spar apparently.
Really need to talk to him about this and I'm going to have him on with Eddie.
Um,
he didn't spar.
He just prepared.
Prepared.
Yeah.
He's want to Eddie's black belts.
Wow.
Really?
Yeah.
To,
he's a black belt.
You should be.
I think he is.
I'm pretty sure it's fine.
I'm fine.
I'm pretty sure Eddie gave him his black belt after he submitted Kevin Lee.
He did.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
He's uh,
he's 10th Planet Guy.
Wow.
That's pretty cool.
It's pretty bad ass.
He's got a nasty Darce choke probably.
He should clearly get the title shot.
It doesn't make sense to me.
Even that when he came back he shouldn't have even gotten stripped.
In hindsight.
I agree 100% and then it's like you have copy Ayp is the title holder fair and
square I guess.
But like you never beat the champion.
Well,
he's more of a legit title holder in my opinion than could be blessed before
Connor because he didn't ally Quinta who wasn't even supposed to be fighting for
the title.
Whereas Kevin Lee is a way more like Ferguson got it from,
well Ferguson Fuck Kevin leak for the interim title because Connor left it.
But Kevin Lee prepared for Tony Ferguson.
They met,
they fought for the interim title and Kevin Lee is like a top contender.
Right?
He's a fucking tough guy.
Obviously he went five rounds with,
could be Connor couldn't go five rounds with,
could be.
And He,
you know,
he put up resistance.
It was,
it was a good fight.
He would never make anyone a title shot.
No.
Maybe in the discussion.
Well he's fighting Kevin Lee.
If he beats Kevin Lee,
he,
that's the next cat look.
Ally Quinta is fucking legit.
He's very legit.
He's underrated.
Like really underrated in my opinion.
I think he's,
the way he got up from Khabib,
taken him down.
Nobody's been able to do that.
He got up like
pretty consistently,
took very little damage on the ground.
Wasn't,
wasn't copied,
was never able to pound him out the way he pounded out.
Connor,
if you go back and watch ally Quinta versus Khabib and Connor versus could be,
you realize how fucking good ally Quinta is.
Just ton of nothing on the ground.
Well he didn't in that fight.
Really.
That's,
that's when Mendez took him down on two weeks notice and it was like if he
didn't,
Gas Mendez would have beat him.
It's true.
It's like he can't fight them right
ground.
Well,
he did very well in the ground and gets Max Holloway,
which was a early in Max's career.
Max was only like 21 at the time.
But uh,
I agree with you.
That's definitely his weakest part of his game and the strongest part of
Khabib's game.
My point was just that ally Quinta did not get beat up on the ground like that
did not get close to being stopped,
went full five rounds and could be clearly won the fight.
But Alec went to provided resistance and provided more of a struggle than Conor
did.
I to honestly thanks to some of the reason that's holding la Quinta back from
the fans being from them thinking of him as like a top is his name.
It's just not,
he has a name of someone who would be like in the early route of Mike Tyson's
punch out.
You say that,
but if you started starching world champions,
nobody would give a fuck about his name.
If he went out there and destroyed could beam and fucking head kicked him into
another dimension.
True.
Good point.
Nobody would give him some of talking about like how hot like celebrities are
and like you wouldn't say that if he wasn't a nine movies.
Like,
who?
I don't know,
like Ryan Reynolds is pretty hot.
Yeah.
Things like that.
Really?
Yeah.
The Moon Guy.
He's in the movie,
right?
Or maybe like day,
even like day and people like is good looking.
I'm like,
fuck yeah,
but like even back then it was like,
but it's like,
no,
he's fine,
he's fine.
But for a comedian for super successful,
so you're like,
oh,
this guy's hot.
It's like,
not really.
Not like,
uh,
um,
Jeremy Renner.
I remember him on commercial days and it was like good looking guy.
But now people are like so gorgeous and it's like that's success is on that.
That's true.
Yeah.
For gals.
And then funding,
it doesn't work like that with girls at all at all.
And matter of fact,
it makes them look a little gross.
What if they're,
if they're,
if they're more successful,
super successful and not that good looking like,
you know,
it works the opposite.
If they're gross looking and then it gets successful.
Like Joan Jett,
Oh fuck Joan Jett.
Now Joan jets.
Hot Man.
Yeah.
Joan jets always been hot.
But in the,
in the Harvey,
there's these women without their fame are like,
get away from me.
Really?
We're talking Joan Jett.
I love rock and roll.
Put another dime that jukebox babies get outta here.
Go put a diamond.
The jukebox or disgusting.
Why?
I disagree strongly.
I'm saying it's only because of her fame.
I always thought she was hot and I know you did,
but when I was in high school,
yeah,
well she was hot when I was in high school.
Like Joan jet is probably 155 years old.
Yeah.
She's playing like Dewey beach next week.
She said the Canyon Club,
which should look like now.
She looks like a,
okay,
well that's a little too issue.
That's Sharon Osborne.
Yeah.
You got the wrong photo.
No,
that's her.
I know Joe.
I was like,
wait,
what?
At first I used to look like are they're like,
yeah,
well you know,
fucking father time fucks is all me father time.
Yeah.
Anyway,
the reason I wanted to come out here talking MMA.
Yeah.
It's because I had this unique experience that a lot of people,
like I mentioned at sometimes and they're like,
oh,
you've been to a UFC.
I'm like,
dude,
I've been to like 50 of them.
And they're like,
how?
It was just this cool thing where I guess in your contract early on you got this
deal,
you get a free companion flight and a free companion hotel and then you started
inviting us and then we started doing comedy shows on Friday night after the
weigh ins and then it became like a thing.
And so these weekends we do one big show and then go to the weigh ins and have
and have a,
the actual UFC the next day.
It was just this fun weekend full of like doing something stand up and also
having fun.
Well,
how about the classic example of you and Dunkin kissing is a good way to start
right away,
right?
It wasn't boring.
It was a fucking wrestling fight.
There was boring.
And so you guys wait until the camera came?
Yeah,
it was on the grout and then you'd charity.
I couldn't stop looking at prostate and I wish I had held it longer.
Oh,
it's Nate Marquardt that's Marquardt was fighting somebody.
Um,
uh,
yeah,
we were given Illuminati sign.
Don't get,
doesn't sit up there normally frosty was always really cool,
but that's up there and make us feel welcome.
You know?
Frosties great guy.
Yeah,
great guy.
And uh,
and then Dunkin was like,
let's give Illuminati signs because he's up there.
He,
he,
he doesn't really care about the sport.
So were just looking at the monitors saying,
seeing the Puck,
a technique of all of it,
of what goes into like the fucking filming of it.
Yeah.
We got to get a joint illuminati.
China
right behind Joe Silva
people.
They're really,
really dumb people.
They think you guys are really in the Illuminati.
People have been saying,
look,
you're in Illuminati.
I know you are.
You and Rogan.
I get people all the time saying,
I'm in the CIA.
That's great.
What a terrible opera view.
Or if they uncovered it,
could you imagine if that was the secret to my career?
Like all the other stuff was just so I could just portray a normal person drug
use history of martial arts,
getting in with the UFC,
becoming the commentator public though to be a CIO seat just to be,
it's like so I can go deep,
deep undercover and nobody would buy it.
It's like what?
You just be better to be a garbage man?
Like Nah,
this is no one would suspect this.
There's people that just want to believe the dumbest fucking conspiracies
period.
The dumbest conspiracies.
Like there was some fucking guy,
one of those info bores guy that was promoting something recently that Hillary
was 50% reptilian.
50% I've heard 30% I could believe,
but 50 50 is a wall half.
Yeah.
See if you can find that.
Someone said she has 50% reptilian
blood.
Well you know that was a David Eick thing for the longest time.
The reptilians.
Yeah,
I remember he was saying he won't talk about that now.
Apparently he's angry when people bring up reptilians cause it's embarrassing
because he was like,
I shouldn't have believed that.
Yeah.
What's a fucking fool heart will hit.
And then he became way more mainstream and then the internet came along and they
were like,
hey,
you remember that fucking reptilian thing?
That's the crazy shit of all to have an answer for that either.
Oh yeah.
I was just making that up for whatever,
what I was back in the early days of Internet,
or I believed it or like I believe that now I realize how crazy that was.
Yeah.
You can say that,
but not like don't bring it up.
Yeah.
There's,
I mean,
look,
there's fucking,
there's real conspiracy.
You know that,
um,
that story about that journalist that was killed by the Saudis this week.
[inaudible]
that's real.
But he was killed.
Yeah.
They finally admitted that they killed him.
The Saudis said,
yeah.
They said that they killed him in a fight,
which is,
if you see the guy you like,
fuck,
this guy's not fighting anyone.
Yeah.
And some of the,
the crown prince's top people,
top security people have been released apparently probably gave him a fucking
$100 million and said,
go chill on a beach somewhere.
Wow.
And we said one of them too was like died in a car accident this week.
I don't know quote that kill a lot of journalists,
man.
No,
not a journalist.
One of the info wars,
real news Twitter band after MSM outcry over Hillary satire.
So it was a satire piece.
I just found the piece and I was like,
there's no way that this is real.
They thought it was that tire.
I don't know who did,
but can I just tell you about,
about Hillary Clinton?
We this DNA test proving she's only half lizard person all the way up,
but like she's doing,
she relates it to clear her name.
Did you know Elizabeth Warren released that thing that says that she's got
actual native American blood,
but it's literally like one,
100024th fucking million trillion.
Wow.
She has like the smallest amount of your bench of Shapiro tweeted about that.
What'd he say?
Oh Fuck Jay.
We've tried to find it.
Your great,
great,
great grandfathers.
But,
and then it was something else,
but I forgot what it was.
See if we could find it.
But I think I'm 1.6% African.
I did one of those DNA tests.
Yeah,
and I'm done.
Have standards.
Goodbye.
I think I'm at least 10 times more African than Hershey issues.
Native American.
Wow.
That's how ridiculous it is.
I might be wrong with these numbers because Jamie and I were trying to work it
out and we're both stupid.
It's fun.
She released that.
It's like c instead of going like,
oh,
I guess I'm not that.
She was lying.
She was also lied to.
Probably her family was like,
well,
you know we have native and have something like that does happen when people do
check.
Like Jamie.
Jamie thought he had a gang gang of native American enemies.
A chat supposedly do.
It's hard to prove.
It's from what I'm trying to find out.
Right.
I can't wait to do one of those tests.
I just have it to see if I'm over 90% 7% Jewish,
other 97% Jewish.
Mine is almost exactly what I thought.
It's mostly Italian.
It's some other European like Irish and English.
You've got to be part monkey.
Yeah.
There's some,
does
some neanderthal I found the editorial in there.
Yeah.
57% more than the average person park on that.
No,
he was trying to prove that he was a minority so we can claim victim hood.
I know,
I know to take the test,
the swab your mouth.
So of course he found an native American and just started making out with them
swab.
And I know who like came up kind of weird.
They're like 98% native Americans so we can get a blood test.
And it wasn't any minority except he was like 2% neanderthal and he goes,
no,
you white people out,
you raped by people.
And that's great.
Yeah.
Stand marsh is a great character.
Uh,
yeah.
So anyway,
the was and done.
So we're doing that.
We keep trying to get on the field Menotti side,
he can see the Monitor,
the Monitor on your table.
Yeah.
And so he goes,
you know,
next time we have to kiss.
And I was like,
aw.
Because as a person I'm like,
I don't want to do that.
But as a comic I'm like,
Oh,
I have no choice.
Yeah.
Obviously that's the right move.
It was like,
God dammit.
So all my,
I'm watching this fight.
Tell me when it is time and then a minute later he goes,
now that's how he just touched tongs.
Uh,
I mean we,
yeah,
we wrapped it around a little.
Woo.
Got To enjoy it.
No,
I don't,
I don't think we touched on.
Maybe we did.
I think he,
he might might've actually,
I think it was a real kiss.
The frost.
He's just watching the Monitor.
It's not even looking at us.
He was like,
I wish I had held a little log that in this.
I thought it was over.
Yeah.
That's intense.
You grabbed his face too.
Like you really loved him.
Oh yeah.
I did.
And put his hand on your shoulder and sort of like a submissive stance and look
at Joe Silva just fight as interesting.
She'll sell these guy's hands crossed.
Totally oblivious to the homosexual activity going on behind his was back when
the fighters could actually make a living in a,
in a sponsorship.
Oh yeah.
We're get a short wouldn't sponsor.
That's a big selling point for Bella tour for a lot of fighters come here and
actually make some cash.
Well,
there's a lot more money to be made if you can get sponsors.
I mean,
shop was making more than $150,000 a fight.
John is short sponsors.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and that flag behind you afterwards,
a flag behind you,
the shorts.
They quickly rush to put the tee shirt on and tee shirts around the week of the
fight.
Like,
you know,
people would pay you to wear it for all your training footage.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I remember when the sponsor,
I remember when they did away with it,
the fighters going,
hey,
come to fucking,
you know,
whatever nightclub.
Come to shush.
We're going to be shorter and I'm going to stump fucking nightclubs.
They haven't begun.
I have to parties.
It's shush.
Yeah.
Someone's going to open up a and then they're like,
hey guys,
you can't do that anymore.
It's gross.
I think that came out of the time,
by the way.
I remember one of the earlier ones in Sacramento.
I see.
I got to see,
luckily not from when you were in the UFC,
but from this middle range to where it is now of like all the fighters would say
at the same hotel and like we'd have the after party there.
We'd all hang out,
four or five fans would show up who knew about it,
but generally it was just a way you can drink with Keith Jardeen and all these
guys and late times,
great times.
I remember you eventually had to make a decision like,
I can't be here anymore.
It's,
it could become overrun with fans,
but for a while it was awesome.
Yeah.
The ring card girl would hae two things changed.
One cell phones with cameras,
they changed because it used to be would just want to say hi.
Then it was everyone had a phone out and they all wanted to take a photo and
they would wait for you in the elevator bank.
So you would get out of the elevator and there would be 50 people there and you
couldn't go anywhere.
You always so late to the event like,
I can't,
I have to go.
Yeah,
I should've left 20 minutes ago.
What about the fence?
I'm like,
I'm doing my job.
Do my job.
Do it for a million fans so you for don't really matter as much.
Running to the fucking way ends.
These guys are starving to death right now and I got to get there.
I can't be late for the Wayne's is televised.
No,
but people would get so angry if he didn't take their photo,
but it was such good times.
I remember it in Sacramento.
There was a hotel bar are all at and it was like this is fucking awesome.
Hanging out casually.
You happen to get into conversations with fighters.
Yup.
Trainers,
della grotty.
People like that.
You just talk.
Yeah,
it completely changed.
It completely changed as a,
well 2005 is really when it changed because that's when the ultimate fighter
came on and when the ultimate fighter took off in the sport became,
it just became much bigger,
like almost within a year.
It was like significantly bigger and then it kept going and then 2000 like what
was the iPhone 2007
six ish.
That's when shit really changed with the cameras on the phones.
Matt come then to eight,
nine and then I was like,
I can't do this anymore.
I have to because we would do shows.
I've got to go to Dennis Hotel.
Well there was no way.
It was just too crazy.
It's like you would get stocked coming into the hotel.
You get stocked leaving the hotel.
People would find your door and knock on your door.
But it wasn't like that and it was so fun.
It was so fun.
Um,
yeah we were there in the fucking salad days.
I remember you're doing the weigh ins once in I believe Fort Lauderdale and this
week we were walking to there with a tap out guys.
Yeah.
I remember scrape telling me scrape ed mass thing like we found it,
this is before the iPhone actually cause he was like,
we found out a way to crank texts people.
What you do is you put in 10 different contacts of a text,
all the same number and they say,
hey,
how you doing?
And then they would just get 10 individual texts.
That's it's,
you just keep doing that.
Fucking stupid.
Yeah.
They would take pictures of people,
but I remember you doing the way it's going and it was back then,
it was only the camps showed up.
Yeah,
it was small.
Yeah.
It was just an a in a,
like a hall,
you know,
not a hallway,
but like a cup,
like a banquet hall and you go,
Oh,
you're almost brought you up.
I was like,
Oh,
I wish you would have to.
I was like,
I would have for sure gotten naked
and nobody would have stopped that.
There wouldn't be like,
ha ha.
I would've gone up their wait in like a lot of the stuff,
like imagine if the UFC was going to hire me today.
They're like,
watch one episode of the podcast.
So I was getting fucked off.
Cleaned it up a little bit.
Yeah.
William Morris wouldn't allow that.
He like
with,
yeah,
I mean they'd be like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
There's no way.
Yeah,
let's get,
let's get Jeff probes.
Yes.
That guy.
He knows a lot about MMA because it really,
no,
no.
Okay.
And that's not sure.
And I was born.
Yeah,
but it was such fucking wild west crazy shit and I was just getting it there.
Just start trading with Eddie.
You started paying for that.
And so I'd see the billboard at the Hyatt now,
the Andaz looking over the comedy store.
I remember saying Ladell couture too,
I think.
And people are like,
oh,
it's a fight.
I'm like,
oh,
what does that mean?
Who are those guys?
And having Taten you go like,
Yo,
they actually fought an epic fight or two,
it might have been three,
I'm not sure.
Um,
and now they're going to have a rematch.
I'm like,
oh cool.
I didn't really know anything about it.
I remember rolling at the old bomb squad and having people talk about it.
I'm like,
what is this thing that you guys were talking about?
I remember Hoists Gracie,
but I don't know who any of these people,
I don't know the terms you're using,
get them on the ground and like it's all,
it's all a question of matchups mattress makes more,
oh,
I'm just like trying to get a half garden.
Trying to figure out how to do that.
A rear naked choke defense got good fast.
Do you got pretty good?
You got pretty good.
I remember you tapping people.
I remember looking over and watching you tap some guys going,
damn,
it was fun.
Fucking Jujitsu if you brought,
if bodies didn't break,
I'm doing Jujitsu.
It'd be the most fun thing to do.
If bodies were way more durable,
like next didn't give out.
Like Eddie's had three surgeries inside of the last year.
He had knee surgery,
he had his back disc replaced in his back and then he just had shoulder surgery.
It's like your body just gets blown apart.
When I tore my meniscus,
I had surgery on it.
They didn't know what it was.
For the longest time.
Your Buddy,
Dr Steve.
Steve Graham,
yeah.
He was like,
Oh uh,
Mris get false negatives 20% of the time.
Just tell them to scope it cause I was like,
it's showing nothing goes.
It's probably,
it's probably that,
just tell them to scope it.
They went in there and found it,
did it right then.
But,
um,
when they did it,
I was like,
there were like,
um,
uh,
what do you do?
What might hurt it?
And I was showing her Jitsu high guard,
just like on the table of myself.
And he was like,
that's what pulling my leg back like that,
you know?
And he's like,
what,
why don't do that.
And I was like,
oh that's I have to do as part of it.
Like it was,
why would you bend your leg like that?
Like that's everyday man,
that's twice a week.
They don't know what the fuck they're talking about.
That's just a flexibility issue.
Yeah.
That never bothered my knees.
Really?
No,
no.
If you're flexible,
that's most kettlebells.
More than chits that yeah,
cause I remember we were doing some stuff like you were doing cleans and presses
and I was like,
Ooh,
for guide doesn't ever lift weights.
This is a pretty explosive movement.
Yeah.
And my technique's not perfect.
So then it's like really opening it up to like more very much.
And it's also when,
when you get sore from doing something like that,
you really should take a long time off.
Like the real hard thing for people that are just starting to lift weights is
the building process.
It's like one of the things that we had talked about with this fitness challenge
was lifting the most amount of weights and in improving your Max weight over the
month.
I was like,
okay
guys,
let's be,
let's slow down here because you guys,
I mean I know Tom Lifts weights a little.
You don't lift weights at all?
No,
I do not.
I lift weights a lot and I'm like,
listen,
if I'm going to improve my macs and things were,
were running the risk of catastrophic injury,
like we're running the risk of tearing ligaments.
Also be bad for the contest.
How somebody you have to drop out.
Yeah,
it could fuck you up pretty bad.
I don't lift Max weight.
I lift like considerably less than my max weight and I don't go to failure.
I do this.
You don't go to failure?
No.
I operate under these principles of uh,
this Guy Pavel Tatsu lean who came up with this company called strong first.
And what the idea is,
is you do less.
Like say if I can do 70 pound kettle bell and I can press it over my head 15
times.
I don't do 15 times.
I do six,
five or six and then I put it down and I leave it alone for like 10 minutes and
then a comeback and I do another five and I do low repetitions and unless I'm
doing conditioning,
in which case I'll use a much lighter weight and I'll do weight.
Yeah.
But Cam does different shit cause like 40 reps of fun.
He does a bunch of ridiculous shit.
He's a fucking maniac.
You can't pay attention to him because he doesn't make sense outside the norm.
He's,
he doesn't make any sense.
He doesn't get injured.
He fucking runs marathons every day and he'll do hundreds of repetitions.
I killed two sets of 25 like four sets of 25 yeah.
He like when he's preparing for one of those big races,
he runs a marathon a day.
Jesus.
Yeah.
It doesn't make any sense,
but also you have to recognize that he built himself into that state over
decades.
Do you know marathon where it comes from?
Yeah.
It was a distance that they had to run to alert someone of something.
Right.
I did know the guy,
I guess his name was marathon,
the right afterwards,
afterwards and died.
But it was more than an actual marathon.
I don't think it,
uh,
it was,
it was 26.2,
I think it was a hundred miles.
I think you've got rid in a hundred.
See if that's true.
The origin of the term marathon,
we call that up.
Origin of marathon please.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Pull that shit up.
Um,
so,
uh,
Cam doesn't count.
Yeah.
I don't understand how he's not always hurt,
but anyways,
who did less?
Oh,
it's 25 miles.
Huh?
So it is announcing the fucking adopt to the defeat of the Persians.
He was just announcing a sports score.
Wow.
It wasn't alerting them.
Say That guy's name.
Try to say his name.
The soldier fit.
Dip,
fitted,
fit,
dip.
Idis fit.
Dip.
Pet is that it is the deputies.
Sure.
I'll do what you want me to hear.
The buzz on the first marathon commemorated the run of soldier for deputies from
a battlefield near the town of marathon grease to areas in for 90 BC.
According to Legend for deputies ran the approximately 25 miles to announce the
defeat of the Persians to some anxious Athenians.
But doesn't say that the guy died.
No,
it does not say died.
See how that guy's running?
Look up.
See where the guys striking with his heel.
It's wrong.
Totally wrong.
Not only is it wrong,
human beings never ran like that before.
They invented those stupid fucking shoes.
I tried it.
I heard you say that before when you're talking about the gold shoes.
So I try to like lead with my,
with yeah,
not so what is it you,
your Paul,
your phone.
Yeah.
That's what you're supposed to lean forward more.
And when you lean forward more,
you strike down and you almost hit with your foot flat.
But what you never want to do is run like that asshole heel down.
That's how people destroy their knees running.
And that was all created by Nike.
Nike created that stupid bubble fat heel shoe.
Because you know,
to give you more cushioning,
but it's just the mechanics of it are totally wrong.
If you ever watch little kids run,
they're run ball of the foot first.
That's natural.
That's how you're supposed to naturally run.
That's your foot is literally designed as a shock absorber.
I run with those minimalist shoes.
My shoes have zero cushioning,
zero,
so I'm running mountains and hills and shit like that.
Even when I hunted elk last week,
see these guys?
Oh yeah,
right on the ball.
Yeah,
the black ones,
the real dark black ones who are good,
they run barefoot,
those fucking guys.
But these guys are,
they're landing flat.
They Dev a lot of cushioning on the shoes.
You have to realize like it and some of these guys are landing heel,
that kind of the back of the heel first and that's because those God damn shoes,
if you didn't have shoes like that,
there's no fucking way that guys all,
he'll see that last guy.
That guy's all heal.
You would never run like that.
It's against the mechanics of the human knee.
Hold it.
Go back to that.
What does that video that does come up?
It's the elite.
What was that video that was just coming up next?
Not to come up?
Neck said Candace running cadence.
Oh,
cadence.
Okay.
Um,
that,
that video,
like that's the only reason that people are running like that.
It's because of the invention of those shoes.
I mean you,
you run quite a bit,
right?
I've seen,
the reason I look for that it's because I've seen a video from the Olympics,
I think it was last year where they showing long distance runners and all of
them had a different stride somewhere running ball foot or first summer running.
He'll first the winter it was different.
I mean I was also goes to all their bodies are different.
They have different,
well,
you can run,
he'll first with those shoes and you can get away with it for a long time.
The,
the,
the issue is that's not the way your body's designed and the only reason why
people are running like that's cause those fucking shoes,
you know?
Um,
if you talk to physiologists and people study anatomy and the loads and the
human nature,
there's massive loads.
There's massive problems with running.
He'll first just not,
you're,
you're not designed,
right.
Uh,
I would say though,
just as a disclaimer,
the biggest problem for most people who were probably those doors,
you don't run it all.
Yeah.
That too.
So go ahead and get up to fucking ass and run and then figure out the exact
right technique later.
I remember when we trying to convince Bert that running on a treadmill is not
the same as running and he was like,
no way.
And they try real running.
He was like,
no swollen charter dude.
It is so much harder.
Of course the fucking coming towards you.
All you have to do is pick your legs up.
But you know,
it's way like for me anyway,
that I've noticed while running on actual ground versus burst pavement ground is
ways here oh ways on my joints.
So I can go longer.
It,
it's a Gig or something.
It's like putting our core,
but you're,
you can run and pavement,
no problem.
As long as you run up hill.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Cause then it's,
then it's toto.
Well it's not just that,
it's you just know pounding when you're running up hill because you're
decelerating.
As you catch yourself and you're pushing off.
It's like you're doing lunges.
The problem is not with pat is unless you're running in a Dali painting,
then it's fucking impossible to keep running up hill.
It's good point.
Good reference to painting.
I will not matter how many,
how many Dolly Robinson's you have in this MMA podcast?
Zero cause the first one ever.
I Walk Downhill basically and then run uphill.
Oh really?
I kind of,
I,
I mean I go way slower.
Downhill.
It's just dangerous.
It's bad for your joints.
Pound like going downhill,
like deceleration,
like running downhill and catching yourself like that.
It's just not good.
But the deceleration only when you,
it's not even deceleration really,
but when you run up hill there's no pounding because you're,
you're just reaching that area and then pushing.
But it wears you out more.
But like your muscles.
But you're right,
the Jordan's.
Okay.
We were hiking the Alps.
This here in July
and man there's uphills with like really have to push,
but the downhills like you're pushing off.
Yeah,
and it's like it just hurts more.
It hurts or quads beats up your knees to really beats up your knees.
I've found that a elk hunting too,
but the really the painful stuff was the downhill.
You're just stopping yourself,
stopping yourself,
stopping herself and then there's also a lot of sliding,
almost like got to push a foot sideways to like go in that way.
It's almost easier.
Yeah.
That's why they have such stiff shoes.
When those you don't like shoes,
you don't come over the edge,
get an edge and you can dig that edge into the ground.
I got some good luck boots for that and it was like really good.
It makes a big difference.
I tried hiking with these minimal issues.
This last trip that I was on,
I didn't like him.
I wasn't a fan.
They're,
they're fine for running if I'm running on a trail.
But for hiking like the human body is just,
we have bitch ass bodies a week with boots.
You want to be able to walk into a creek without having to worry about like
there's going to soak my shoes,
socks to the next four hours.
Yup.
Yeah,
yeah.
Gortex he wanted that Goretex lining of your boots by the way.
So after that fight,
um,
after that,
me and Dunkin Kissing,
yeah.
Uh,
there was a blog that went up pretty fast that said,
uh,
two board bearded dudes get rough sea.
And,
uh,
I got a text from a guy just got a new phone,
a new flippy and uh,
somebody,
I didn't know who it was.
Somebody texted me like,
Oh,
you two are quite the social media darlings last night were do that.
I hadn't responded to how it was.
And then,
um,
later I looked through my,
I messages through Dana and I was like,
was not mad.
I don't think he does,
but you never quite know.
I know,
right?
Cause you're like,
you are a CEO,
you know,
in addition to being this cool fucking regular dude who curses all the time,
you're also a c e o
which is like the WHO I don't normally get along with the gigantic sports
organization.
Yeah.
That guy.
It's interesting meeting that guy to having like dinners with them and like
converse it casual conversation to listen to like a highly successful person and
just how they like normally act once he dropped the guard,
you know.
Um,
it's just interesting.
He's like,
yeah dude.
For sure.
Driven.
Yeah.
He,
he loves making deals and all the,
all the ships involved in it.
But um,
hearing you guys talk about like the fucking meet heads of Boston fighting and
stuff like the top two meatheads finally met.
I remember the story he told was it was like Whoa,
Boston where Burt Dana came up and where I came up,
the sparring was awful.
It was,
uh,
he,
he sparked a lot in south Boston and um,
I,
I sparked in Summerville and a in revere and a couple of these other places.
It was everybody would beat the shit out of each other.
There was no real sparring and one RN.
Rivera Rivera Rivera.
Yeah,
they,
there was no,
uh,
you're supposed to spar.
Wow.
This is a lot of debate on this,
but most people think you should spar at like 60 to 70% maximum.
Everybody's part 100% or they just fought.
Everybody fought.
Everybody got brain damage.
100%
that's my boss is how it is a Harvard or you're a Dork and the women aren't the
best looking.
If there was one
stage,
you're challenging me and we sat down.
It's like one of these things that comics do.
What do they say?
Something like real dark,
just your comic friends and they're like,
you should do that on stage.
It's like this challenge of like,
oh right you are.
He goes on
stage at the comedy connection in Faneuil Hall and he will,
I don't remember the exact wording of it,
but you were like a,
you know,
the problem with Boston is women are just really not that good looking.
This is,
and people like,
I love that training it to now I can go after a crowd and just like,
you can go with maybe you want,
I'm being honest,
you know,
training.
Yeah.
The way that you can see that in like a,
in like a cat Williams when he's shitting on Michael Jackson when he was still a
hero and it was like boom.
He goes,
fuck you children fescue.
He's a molester.
Yeah.
That go right at them.
I don't care how you feel.
Well,
I'm justified in this.
Super justified with that.
Yeah.
I mean that was just some xy.
Boston women are disgusting.
Even if they're good looking,
they're voices are garbage.
Oh fuck me and my pussy fucking Quia.
Um,
those were fun times too,
man,
because when we first started going on the road together,
like one of the more fun things was,
well,
you was really fun hanging out and doing shows,
but it was also fun saying like,
you can't get fired.
Kicked out.
Did,
was such an influential
time.
I stand up that specifically where it was like,
we're at the hotel five minute walk from Faneuil hall and you're like,
let's get high.
And I was like,
Nah,
I'm about four months crazy kick at high right now.
That's what I had been high 20 times maybe.
And you're like,
why?
I'm like,
because I won't do good.
He goes,
so I'm like,
what do you mean?
So he goes,
so,
but then he goes,
you won't get fired.
They didn't hire you.
You can't play here.
It's 450 seats.
And also like it because it's too far for you to go to feature and you just way
too big for you to headline.
So I'm hiring you and I don't care if you get too fucked up.
So smoked pot.
And I was like,
yeah,
why don't you to feel free?
And that there's these moments when you get high and you go on stage where,
and they don't always happen,
but there are moments where you take a right turn into brilliant Ville and that
right turn doesn't exist.
Sometimes if you're sober,
you're sober,
you'll stick to the script.
But if you're high,
you're like,
so what if I did fuck my dog?
Let's try,
let's try this for a while.
How to know where you might come up with this premise or this tagline or this
thing that comes from you being in this altered state of conscious.
Yes.
And you can't do it.
Any comic listening,
I would not advise you doing it on a big showcase.
We have to show like William Marsh and Mclennan or when you're taping something
where it's important,
but for workout sets when you're really just trying to get work out of this.
So,
so,
um,
and back then I could get hot.
Now you and I,
we get high for a couple hours,
you know,
maybe then I was high for nine hours.
I smoked three hits.
There was no like,
so anyway,
we had two sets at night or Friday or Saturday night.
And uh,
the first set was awful.
I,
I forgot what I was saying.
I had no idea where I was going.
I remember,
isn't that bad?
I was bad.
No,
no,
no.
Parts of it were really far to have it.
Okay.
But then by the second set now,
then you went on for an hour,
then we had a half hour break and then want to again by then I come down a
little bit.
And the second set was what you were talking about.
Free flowing.
Get high about an hour and a half before you go onstage.
Not like right before I fucked up and got a high right before.
That's not,
that's not wise.
What's wise,
isn't it
on your way down.
You already know where it's gone and now you're coasting.
You know what Edgar would do medic or we're due for a while.
He would go on late at the comedy store and he wouldn't get high off that.
You know,
your first hit of the day is like your biggest one.
And um,
cigarette smokers have the suits.
Only time you get a buzz,
that first cigarette you know it,
but your first we'd hit,
it's the biggest one.
He wouldn't smoke all day.
He'd have a 12:15 AM spot.
And when they go,
Hey Matt,
we're letting the Tony,
he'd go,
cool,
run to the main room,
smoke a bunch.
And that three minutes and then go on stage.
Ooh.
Yeah,
and he'd be going up and feeling it while he's off.
Like it wouldn't even hit him until he's two minutes on.
Oh Jesus.
He did that for like six months.
Be Good if you had notes.
Yeah.
And if you followed what you talked about already.
That's what I tell them when they play Clandestina or comedy underground,
they call and Toronto.
Wow.
That place is crazy.
I'm like,
any advice?
my advice is bring a set list.
I normally don't say that,
but this is one you will lose your place.
There was no air in that room.
Once green is only pot like you were breathing pot and exhaling pot.
It was all pot.
My Buddy Minola so he was like,
I don't smoke.
And then he's in the back for 20 minutes.
Like two of them high shit.
Yes.
Tripoli.
Tripoli wasn't getting high back then and yes you are standing.
He was barbecued.
That's where I started to believe secondhand smoke is a real thing.
I didn't think it was until then.
People that don't think it's real,
it's great.
When we used to mock tape cause take,
didn't want to get high and we would just smoke pot and Tate would have to stick
his head out the window like an ostrich.
I feel like what the fuck is wrong with her?
He was worried and you want to get hotboxing if that's when we used to get vans.
Remember we used to get vans for awhile?
Conversion vans.
Yeah.
We would rent vans because it was so many of us.
Oh
yeah.
We would entourage it and red van would film it.
We would just have shenanigans and every time we went to
you of course.
And then Eddie Tate and red band as the non comedians and then me and Duncan or
me and dia or whatever.
Um,
there was a shitload of us.
Yeah.
So five,
six people and then we would feast.
We'd go to these fucking amazing restaurants.
Fogo a lot.
We went to a lot of photos.
It brings me back to one of my memories,
I believe it was Cincinnati was nearby.
Right near the hotel.
Do you want us to Korea?
Yeah,
right across the street.
Yeah.
And a as relieving fucking newly a botox.
Uh,
I came in and like,
dude,
that's fucking Vandelay and he was,
he was the most fierce pregame fighter.
The way he'd look at you like,
I want to kill you for taking this flight.
Nobody was scary that him and his prime cro cop was scary because he would just
be so calm.
Like I don't care what do this cop stared him down more than anybody ever stared
Vandelay town.
He wouldn't break,
it could move.
Cro Cop was a straight up killer,
Croatian Croatian antiterrorist squad.
They begged for mercy and I've showed them and he's a world class kickboxer like
he wasn't afraid of Vandelay strike and he was a heavyweight and Vandelay really
wasn't a heavyweight.
But anyway,
we saw him checking in and we went to eat.
He was in that true husker Rhea 15 minutes late.
Like he threw his shit down and came in.
They were like so excited about it.
Look,
look at Cro cop.
Wow
Dude.
Nobody's stared down.
Cro Cop back then,
that was when cro cop was at the peak was Japanese got going through his routine
and it's like fuck.
And I'm pretty sure this was before,
uh,
Cro cop really had sort of mastered MMA.
He was coming over as a straight kickboxer and they had different rules for him.
The rules for Cro cop where like you can only fight on the ground for like 30
seconds they had and if the fight went to a distance it would be a draw.
Yeah,
because he really didn't have a lot of experience with take down defense or any
MMA fighting back then.
And the,
he didn't get botox.
He
had his face reconstructed cause his nose,
he had been in so many brawls,
his nose had completely flattened where he couldn't breathe out of it and he had
so much scar tissue over his eyes that his eyes were drooping down.
So He'd get cut instantly.
Any,
any punched him would hit him with open them up like a gas.
And he and his nose was completely flat.
So they took a chunk of his rib and rebuilt his nose and he had his nose built
big so he could breathe out of it more.
And then he had all the scar tissue from his eyebrows and then pull back.
And according to Dana,
I dunno,
but the is like,
it got,
it's done in Brazil on the cheap and it's just like wasn't,
it didn't,
I didn't really make them look like Vander.
Wow.
So he went from Vandelay Silva.
It's like Vandelay Silva has the most profound facial form change in all of MMA
because he went from pretty,
if go back,
because I ended up Silva Vandelay Silva versus go to Vandelay Silva versus Dan
Henderson one.
When they first fought in pride,
he,
he was a normal,
actually pretty good looking guy,
like regular good looking guy.
And then by the time he left pride,
his face was just smashed in.
By the time he fought chocolate Dell,
His nose had been literally flattened.
Wow.
For from punches and kicks and not just from fights,
but also from training.
The training that he did it shoot to box and karate.
Ba was legendary.
It was fucked up.
Fucked up.
That also okay would bring me to another thing.
We got to go to Brazil one time.
We didn't do a show that time,
but that's him versus Dan Henderson can make that a little bigger.
So you could see.
Yeah,
super normal kid.
Just a normal combat ass.
That was the first fight.
Oil fought Dan Henderson Chin look like it was drawn on.
Guys got him hooked.
Somebody fucked up.
What?
He's drawing a bone,
which I let him let him see that picture of annually above that with the eye all
fucked up.
That was him from that fight.
Oh really?
And Henderson connected with a haymaker of her right hand and fucked up his up.
Smile on that.
Like look at this bad.
Look at this cool picture on by the tick.
But you mean look at vandelays face there in comparison to his face later on his
career.
Totally different.
Dan Henderson looks exactly the same.
He looks like the same guy.
He's just an other version.
He might be one of the toughest guys ever lived.
So tough.
Yeah.
Dan is just a fucking picture up there with the tattoos and the shoulders go to
that one.
Now that's him after facial reconstruction,
make that larger c that's after the facial reconstruction has settled in,
you know,
or we saw him right then and he just fought real recently,
a couple of weeks ago.
He's still fighting gun knocked out by rampage.
Rampage flatline them.
Wow.
Yeah.
Pages still fun to Yup.
Rampage still carries that power.
That was when he KOD rampage Kao to him in the UFC with and knocking him through
the ring through the pride was one of the coolest.
Yeah,
I saw that later.
I mean,
I,
you know,
way later I come to the UFC and it's like all these highlights,
this backlog of highlights of MMA mile,
especially if the UFC purchase price.
Yeah.
Rio was really cool.
It's a place to go.
And actually that fight that in terms of the audience response,
the two biggest ones were Sylvia couture in Columbus.
First time they'd ever been in Columbus.
And that real fight Josie Aldo versus,
uh,
that was a Chad Mendez,
right?
Which one?
The one in Brazil,
wasn't it?
It was a spinning back kick.
Oh,
that was Terry.
Adam versus a Edson Barboza dude from day from fight,
one of the undercard the place was so that you could feel it shaking.
And I remember them chanting something in the crowd.
Cause Dana did smart.
There's one of the first like foreign ones and he made a Brazilian fighter on
every,
on every fight.
He fucked up a little by having a couple of times Brazilian verse Brazilian,
but at every fight and they were chanting something in the audience.
Yeah.
You were like,
you go to the translator,
like what are they saying you're going to die?
It was like,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
They didn't play games,
man.
Oh my God.
That's when they were like legit.
And I believed it.
Like we've got to figure out how we're gonna get Chelsea on and out of here.
Fights Anderson here.
And I'm like,
come on.
And then you go there.
You're like,
oh,
I believe it now.
Yeah.
Well,
they're fiercely,
fiercely nationalistic.
And also that's where I'm at.
Started.
I mean,
MMA martial arts started in the Orient.
They started in Japan and China and,
but in terms of like legitimate,
mixed martial arts valley to though those no rules,
fights,
that's all from Brazil.
Men,
Brazil changed Jujitsu.
I mean,
you leave the airport and they're these giant,
um,
like Jujitsu guys in,
he's like looking at each other like it's part of their organization culture.
It's huge over there.
And you know,
I had on a Rafael Lovato who's like one of the top Brazilian Jujitsu fighters in
the world who fights for Bela Tarr now,
and he's actually an American from Oklahoma at fights,
uh,
you know,
and really represents Brazilian Jujitsu.
But he was saying that like,
for the longest time,
the Brazilians dominated the world championships.
He was one of the first Americans to win a gold medal in the world
championships.
But for the longest time,
like even to this shame,
the Brazilian still have a disproportionate number of gold medalist.
Yup.
Yeah.
It's huge part of the culture and they're so proud,
you know,
so proud.
That was one of the coolest places I've ever been through.
I remember also when we went to
Australia to Sydney and uh,
we did do a show that we did two shows.
That was cool.
But um,
it was in your contract FirstClass companion ticket way before we were ever
going to go to Australia for that.
And then it was just as a UFC grew,
which is grandfathered in.
And so I remember Dana coming up to me half joking and half serious,
just going,
do you know how much I fucking ticket cost?
And I'm like,
what?
$25,000,
dude,
that's how much I'm paying for you to go to Australia.
Yeah,
those were good times.
I almost want to like,
Bro,
put me in coach or give me fucking 12 of that.
I could use the money.
I'll split the difference.
Don't suffer for 14 hours for 12 grand.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Those are like apartments.
If like a little apartment.
I was so proud.
Yeah,
it's a girl told me he brought him the year before and he was like,
dude,
get ready.
It's going to be so good.
They give you socks that I jerked off into
such a fucking cool grand experience.
Yeah,
you can do a lot of fucking UFC live,
man.
I went to,
let's just talk about Anderson for a cause.
I believe my very first UFC was at the Pearl.
Yes.
At the palms.
I think it was Anderson Bearse.
Chris Leeman.
Yes.
It was fun fight.
Yeah.
I guess Anderson,
I might've been his first fight in the UFC was okay.
And people were like,
yeah,
he's highly touted but not crazy.
Like he's the best.
Just like I knew who he was and I was telling everybody like whatever the
betting line is,
it's off.
You told me that on um,
on,
um,
fuck Glover to sharer.
Oh,
you're like,
hey dude,
I don't really tell you.
Go fucking take money on this.
Put all the money.
He was home early in the undercard Glover foot.
Kyle Kingsbury,
just like people don't know.
And you know,
Glover,
I was like,
what's the line?
It goes,
it doesn't matter to her.
He'll when he got a rough deal man,
because he couldn't get a visa to fight in the UFC for a loan for six fucking
years.
For six years.
Glover had a toil and other countries,
he was one of the best ever.
He was fucking phenomenal back then man.
And I think,
you know,
when we got them in the UFC was at the tail end of his greatness.
Honestly.
I mean I think we never really got a chance to see glow over at his very best in
the UFC.
It's kind of like a Jackie Robinson.
Like what were the steps would have been if he could have played his whole
career,
it's euro or something like that.
He's one of those guys that,
I mean,
I remember when he fought,
so could you,
he fought.
So could you,
I think it was in the dubby c and the early days of the WEC when it was in
northern California and he was a chocolate Dell sparring partner and it was one
of the rare times that he got to fight in the U S and I remember watching him
fight and I would hear about them.
I think Hackman told me about him too because he was training with chuck and I
was like,
that guy's a mother fucker.
He is so good.
He was so solid and he was like,
you know,
training with Hackleman and training with Chuck Liddell in the early days when
you know they're just savages,
man and his,
he had wrestling too.
There was one thing that a lot of Brazilians didn't have.
They were more Jujitsu oriented and he was a wrestler as well.
There was Bob Ballou.
Lou had a real good wrestling base too,
and that was the first guy I remember making money by leaving the UFC.
He was one of the straight guys.
I'll get paid as a UFC vet.
I have a name and I'll get paid a bunch off this fucking chuck fight,
you know,
I'll get paid a bunch of the rest of my career until everybody started going.
And then it's like,
it wasn't worth that much anymore to be a form of Europe's force opened up.
You know,
a lot of people realize that there was like,
there was a legitimate venue and they weren't showtime.
Strikeforce was on showtime.
Yeah.
You mean when Kimbo fought there?
I mean it all of a sudden it was a big fucking deal.
That was a lead XC let the chick that went on to uh,
to uh,
Gina Carano and they would like make ms people and that's actually where you've
heard about Cyborg.
Yup.
Yup,
Yeah.
There was like a lead XC and that.
And then,
um,
you know,
and strike force,
those were two legit venues outside the UFC that really kind of,
because the UFC wasn't as big back then.
Right.
And then they were pretty legit and there were more men,
you could get it,
you didn't have to pay per view it.
Right.
You could actually just watch him,
which is what Bellah tour has going for it too.
But now Bella is on that new thing.
Does zone Dazn do you know what that is?
Well they,
what they're doing is they're splitting,
it's like a streaming service.
They're splitting half the half the fights.
Uh,
Bella tour on paramount,
which is used to be spike Fairmount.
Half the fights on this DAZN network.
But what's crazy is the DAZN network just gave Canelo Alvarez $365 million.
They just gave him this giant deal because they had no Canelo.
Just one could just beat triple g unconcerned about boxing.
You know what I'm saying?
Of blocks.
You know what?
I fully left it.
What we went to your place once you're old house.
Maybe you Eti,
maybe a couple other people.
We were watching some pride stuff that you Dvr,
right?
And it cut off the last fight cause it went long.
Oh that's right.
And then we watch watched boxing,
boxing.
And after watching two hours of MMA,
you see a guy get knocked down and they're just like,
go to work.
Go to word.
Let them get up.
You're like,
what the fuck is this?
So much hugging and fucking boxing socks.
It's great if you watch really good boxers and if you'd know you're going to go
see boxing Canelo Alvarez fight.
That happened a couple of weeks ago.
It was a really good fight.
I thought triple g.
Well I thought it was a real close fight,
but if I was going to give it to someone,
I think I would've given it to triple g but it was close enough where you can
go,
okay,
this isn't a robbery but good fight,
but leg kicks and and and take downs and it just makes fighting more interest as
I was just way too many fucking,
let's see what the judges said.
No one.
So nobody really one.
They just got it just did better.
Yeah.
No,
we're not Beto guy.
Right?
Rarely.
I mean it happens rarely.
It happens less.
Yeah.
The thing about Pacquiao,
Mayweather was like,
I mean you could have kept fighting,
right?
So what have we decided?
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
After 12 rounds,
they could've gotten 12 I like the early pride,
like the early UFC with hoist,
it's like you're going to find me for 35 minutes.
Right.
And then we'll see eventually I'll fucking wear you down.
Yeah.
That's what Nate always says.
Like if this was war,
you'd be dead.
Yeah.
It's like I choked her out that he's able to kept choking you and then just put
a fucking twisted your neck.
Yeah.
I mean if someone came along today and did no time limit fights,
I wonder like if you had like three big no time limit fights like Nate versus
Connor,
John Jones versus DC,
you know,
and have just three
giant fights and have no time limit,
no fight,
Ooh,
carry thing.
To go into that kind of a fight.
That's a different feeling like would hoist went into and those early days of
the UFC,
it took a lot of abuse just to get like pass guard and that slow like eight
minutes later he's like so slowly move.
We're not in a rush.
It's weird how it changes your fight plan based on this outside influence.
Well.
People also have to remember hoist fought guys that were so much bigger than
massive,
like chemo,
chemo and chemo like was a giant roid it up dude and was hitting him with bombs
and and hoists was on its back and finally caught him in an arm bar and then
couldn't continue.
He couldn't fight after that.
He was to focus to fight later and he couldn't fight.
He was just,
he couldn't fight in the,
in the next fight.
He was just too bad.
That tournament's right?
Yeah.
Crazy.
Twice in a night.
They were three times in a night.
Yeah.
That's doesn't look out young.
Big John Looks,
Oh my Christ.
He's not even going facial hair.
Here's chemo.
Chemo was giant.
I mean he was so huge at Jesus' tattooed on his stomach.
Look how big he is to him.
Yeah.
That was a crazy ass fight,
man.
That's what it was like.
What is this whole sport?
I remember getting it.
My friend's like,
yeah,
college dorm as hell.
Son.
Helson Gracie in the back.
I mean that was the clan man.
Those the,
the Gracie clan.
Who was the Gracie that was supposed to be,
but they were like,
you're too good.
It'll fuck everything up.
Hixon but the thing about it was not just that Hickson was too good,
but also that Hixon wouldn't listen like no one could control Hixon.
Oh really?
Like,
yeah,
cause Horian created the UFC and Horian was the oldest brother,
Jorge and Helson.
I Dunno,
I'm not sure which one was right at it.
There was no feelings for the route.
17 seconds in a fucking font had to do that.
I mean,
he had to close the distance to get ahold of them.
You had the door open.
He's like,
wait,
wait.
He's like,
Oh fuck.
This is sucky.
Yeah,
ready,
go.
Yeah.
And Chemo had is risk taped up,
but not as knuckles.
It's crazy tired.
Bare knuckles,
stomps soccer kicks.
You can do anything back then you can kick in the balls,
you can knee in the balls you could haul.
Yeah,
right.
That's right.
I remember that guy just kept wailing on the balls that 30 times a whole bunch
of the guys like,
all right,
all right.
Wow.
He's hackney versus Joe.
Simon,
he fucking bald them on Joe Simon and went to jail for rape.
He went to jail for a yacht and then not,
he murdered his cellmate.
He went to jail for a gang rape that they arrested him for something else and
they did a DNA test done.
I once found out that he was a part of a gang rape.
Yeah.
Look how skinny pig John Is.
So small.
He just felt looking so sexy.
Like a model.
This is 93 right?
So this is a long ass fucking time ago,
man.
25 years.
Yeah.
And Hoist headbutts he that hoist with the head,
but it's like the balls please fall down so I can do what I need to do.
Well,
I mean he really didn't a wrestling background.
I mean,
you see how high his hips are,
you know,
he didn't,
he didn't drop down and go for a double.
He was basically claim changed.
Yeah.
He was basically clinching and then hoping he get to fight to the ground with a
trip and there he goes.
And then when he tripped him,
chemo wound up on top of him,
which is hilarious.
Like this flatten out.
Had his back is terrible,
terrible position.
Blue Hoist places just happy that he's on the ground.
Dude,
keep wrestling with me.
I'll fucking get you.
But look at this chemos riding his back.
But Chemo is maybe 80 or 90 pounds heavier than him.
It seems a lot to get off your back.
You voice was like one 75 g two yeah,
he was one 75 and chemo is easily,
easily two 50 he was a big fucking guy man.
And there's no back of the head.
So he's got to protect themselves with distance and know like,
and also chemo is holding on to hoist as Geeky.
But now look,
you fucked up,
you got tired,
tired,
look wide open God.
And then he just didn't even try to,
yeah,
but he bought,
he bucked him off just from sheer size,
but chemo just got exhausted because when you're that big,
if you don't have like a real rigorous strength and conditioning program,
you just get fucking trying going in there.
You've got no idea.
Oh no arm bar,
but looks not that good.
A sloppy.
He's tired,
man.
He's carrying this fucking big guys.
Wait.
And again,
they didn't have strength and conditioning back then,
man.
No one knew what the fuck they were doing.
This was all just cut.
Wade.
He didn't cut anyway.
Didn't know shit about nutrition.
I mean in 93 man that now he,
I remember he got ahold of that hair and he got a fist full of hair and started
punching him in the face.
Really?
Chris Distance for their arm triangle there.
No look at it.
Still can't cut it at fist full of hair.
It's not letting go of this.
He's a bitch.
I got your hair fucked up,
man.
Should get a haircut.
Yeah,
you try to be sexy Tong Po Bullshit.
But you know,
this is,
we learned so much about martial arts from these fights because everybody had
these ideas like woodwork and what wouldn't.
And then once they did that it's like,
oh I have to work on my ground.
And then that evolved and I have all been involved.
Well like the old opened up Jujitsu schools worldwide everywhere.
And everybody wanted to be a Gracie.
You know guys,
we're changing their name to Gracie guys were like Marion Gracie's just to have
the Gracie name guys and marry a female Gracie and then changed their name to
Gracie.
I mean it was crazy.
It was a difference between you making $1 million and you make it nothing.
Nobody wanted to go to Fred's Jujitsu.
What wanted to be a part of the Gracie Academy,
you know,
like look,
you just get all that hair on the ground.
What does that,
oh,
it's a hair chemo.
His hair.
If he pulled a fistful of fucking hand,
pulled it out.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
They're both so tired.
Oh,
exhausted Ben.
And this is the only thing fortunately.
How long's this Viko I think it went seven minutes,
if I have to remember exactly.
It's crazy.
They're both so worn out.
It looks like it's more of,
so it's,
what's that James Right here?
It's about to end here for 22 oh hey.
He catches him,
keeps going for the arm,
Bar,
the triangle,
and eventually it's like,
I'll get one over here.
He gets it.
So it was like four 28 he's catching the arm bar.
So this is like first round.
I wonder,
I wonder if UFC today even knows what he's going for here.
A hoist does chemo,
chemo.
What are you doing?
I don't get it.
That's it.
I think he more tap cause he was exhausted than anything.
Like look at him.
He's exhausted.
Made a bear.
He got the arm bar for sure.
But I mean barely.
But then hoist was so beaten down by this fight that he couldn't go on,
but Hixon would have destroyed chemo.
It would have been a completely different thing because Hickson was strong as
fuck man.
And Hickson was,
there's Joseph Hickson was a different animal.
Like Hickson was much more physically imposing.
He was about one 9,200 pounds and he was smaller than chemo,
but he was jacked bodies.
Look at it.
Fuck it.
His body is just like rustler body.
Damn.
Well marginal wrestler bought it.
Yeah.
More bodybuilder.
Whereas hoist is just,
if you saw hoist with his shirt off,
you would think that guy's a fighter.
Wrap you up like a fucking package.
So back to Anderson though.
Yeah,
so my book ends with him are that first leap and fight and then shattering his
leg,
which I was in the front row for which you didn't even believe it.
It didn't make sense to see a leg move like that.
You're like,
I don't,
I don't get it.
It looked like somebody filled up a sock with pebbles and just like hit it
against something and it's like it doesn't,
it didn't make sense and it was so gross.
But in the interim,
seeing that first Charleston and fight when he was,
I mean he won 400 a half rounds.
Chael Sonnen,
he almost won the title and then to cut that,
I mean it was a la,
such a legendary sports thing,
not UFC,
but sports thing.
How this guy's down like crazy in a title fight.
A guy who's never been tested was finally tested and was losing.
It was over.
This guy could,
Chael Sonnen was beating him.
He figured them out and then to get that triangle with 40 seconds left,
two minutes left.
It was,
but I remember what's so clear and indelible in my head is afterwards we're at
the entrance,
everyone's cleared out of the stadium.
We're at the entrance to the,
um,
to the,
under the,
you know,
the caves of the,
of the stadium,
whatever it was.
And it's me,
you,
I think Dana,
Randy was there and we're all talking.
And then every once in a while somebody's mind would go to that fight and you
just see him go like,
yeah,
I think the weather is pretty nice here.
And then you see someone go like,
like,
you couldn't believe it.
I remember seeing Randek a tour dude.
Like,
well,
like why do this?
Four minutes into the fight grabs a hold of it or four rounds in the fight,
grabs a hold of that,
syncs up the triangle and gets a triangle armbar combination and tabs him.
Wow.
And this is an Anderson came into that fight,
injured and are Anderson had a fucked up rib entering into that fight and a lot
of people thought he should have pulled out.
What kind of weird edit is this?
All the blurriness,
all these strange fan,
and it was nuts.
It was nuts for that guy.
He'll come see how he's holding his side and the mode.
The first,
that was the first trash talk fight ever remember to Oh,
Chels son and people forget how good he was a talking shit.
He was the best,
the best.
He was the best.
When I come it,
when Anderson Silva walks into the ring,
you could hear a mouse pissing on cotton.
When I walk in,
it's thunder.
I mean the promos he would cut.
Yeah.
We're just the APP that hadn't been done yet.
Now we've done a lot.
Well,
Conor Mcgregor Prob,
you know,
it's arguable that shale was even better than Conor.
If you take time period into accounts,
no one was doing right.
He was the first.
Yeah,
and he was building up fights as a heel for the first time ever and brought them
in a little bit later.
People forget how to chill,
could fight.
If you go back to really,
to me,
his,
one of his most impressive victories was Nate Marquardt because he fought Nate
Marquardt wouldn't meet,
Nate was one of the best and he ragdolled them and it was a bloody crazy chaotic
fight.
And He,
you know,
he basically dominated him with wrestling,
chill just fought last week.
He just got knocked out by fader.
Damn.
He's stopped by fate.
Yeah.
And you know,
he had some good moments in that fight.
He had faith doors back.
He tried,
he tried to roll them over.
There's a move that you do go under the Chin when you have someone's back,
you go under the Chin and then you,
you somersault over and try to carry with momentum.
Try to carry them over.
But it's a core strength move head and arm.
Well you,
yeah,
he had,
he had the back and he was kind of like riding high on the back end.
He went,
he felt like he had a grip under the chin.
I don't know how he held his hands.
But what you do is when you have a guy's back,
you,
you hold it like this and then you go forward.
So you take them forward with you.
That way you have their back.
When you're on your back,
you could cinch up a body triangle.
You could cinch up the choke but fade or shook them off and then beat them on
the ground.
Yeah,
watch how he does it.
So he tries to flip them,
oversee,
but he lost.
Fuck,
he lost control and then boom,
hey makers coming down from one of the greatest ground and pound experts of all
time and giant difference that was getting that are not cutting it also,
you know,
chill fought one 85 fade or has been heavyweight his whole life.
It's like,
you know,
there's a lot of factors in there,
but uh,
it was a good fight for as long as it landed long as it lasted.
Brother,
one of the cool things that we've gotten is the big ability to hang out casually
with these fighters.
Like having breakfast with Randy Singh,
him having with enough times with you that I remember one time I was like going
into a buffet or whatever or the hotel,
like free breakfast and like looking around and just having him go sit with me.
Yeah.
I'm like,
okay.
Just like,
oh,
you're just such sought after it.
I'm just like,
I'm talking about nothing but
some of my favorites were in Chicago to going to the way ends and then like,
let's go to the show and then just junk drive with Clay Guido
and like,
I'll drive you just,
it's his city,
it's his city.
And he's like,
come with me.
And were like,
okay,
and you white knuckling,
holding onto the front seat.
I see he's swerving with a brown paper bag drives like he fights
and I'm just like,
I accept that.
So either way about it and he would just go in for it on these highways.
He knows.
And then I believe the rain and it was just like,
I wish I was like so fun.
Yeah.
Another one that I remember early on early on,
John Jones,
he wasn't anything then,
which foreign?
Oh,
maybe something like that.
Um,
meeting him,
uh,
talking about shit,
and I could talk about this now because it's not no longer a banned substance in
the UFC,
but like,
uh,
talking about weed and was like,
yeah,
let's smoke bro.
He wasn't anything,
it wasn't anything and just going like,
he was like,
who's got wait?
I'm like,
oh,
Rogan's got it.
But he's in his hotel room and texting you flip phone,
texting you doc when it wasn't cool.
You don't have to have like hip to have a flip phone where it's like,
that's all anybody had.
That's how long ago.
And then just go on.
Like maybe it's that,
maybe it was early,
uh,
iPhone,
but like just going,
hey man,
are you up?
And you're like,
y'all kind of,
and go to sleep.
And was like,
Fuck John.
I think he's doesn't want us up there.
And then be like,
no,
let's go.
He's got the weed.
Let's go.
Because some fan gave it to us.
Right?
You had this fucking him like tin foil of Weed and um,
and just knock on your door and be like,
what?
And you're like,
uh,
she retired and it was like,
um,
do you have that?
We'd like to come on,
I want to go to sleep.
It's like,
man,
John want to smoke?
And you're like,
you looked at us,
you open the door fully looked at me and this young fighter and you were like,
come on in.
And we all smoked pot together and this hotel room and fucking wherever it was,
I think Montreal.
Ashley's Montreal.
Yeah.
And you're just a fun time.
And then seeing this guy move on to become the baddest motherfucker on the
planet.
But we also had a conversation with him about,
I was,
I wanted him to go to a different camp.
That's right.
He was training in fucking youtube videos in New York.
Yeah.
With his buddies in a garage.
You too good.
I'm like,
you should be in a real cash.
That's right.
We had that over weed in the hotel room.
He's like,
you really think so.
I go,
I know.
So I know.
I go,
you only have a certain amount of time in this thing.
I go and your time should be invested with a real coach.
Who's going to hone your skills.
I grow you.
You could be an all time.
Great man.
Wow.
Yeah,
I remember telling him that and he's like,
you really think so.
I go,
I know.
So I know.
So you,
you really got to move on.
I forgot about that part of it.
That,
how influential was that in the fucking future of mixed martial arts?
So I hope it helped.
You know he did.
He went to Winkeljohn Jack's Jackson,
uncle John Eventually.
I mean,
he'd probably be,
we might've done it anyway.
He might owe knows,
but uh,
I,
I think it was a good conversation to have with a young guy.
You know,
I was like,
listen man,
you,
you have real talent.
Like you could really be something,
but you gotta be,
you gotta be coached by guys who are going to find out your tendency technique
isn't worth,
isn't going to go take you that far.
Well,
I mean,
fucking,
he was so good.
Who knows how far he might've been a world champion,
even with the camp that he was in.
He's so good and his wrestling is so powerful and he's so physically talented,
but it made a big difference for him to go to Jackson's and be able to train on
a regular basis with world class fighters being there on a daily basis with
Carlos condit who is,
you know,
at the top of his game back then.
And I mean Keith Jardeen and they just had a massive,
they had ruined tailors,
the,
they called it the ring of fire where you would go five rounds of sparring with
to get ready for a fight with a different high level.
I mean,
highest level fighter.
So like Nate Marquardt like,
cool.
That was where I won't out of here at Giardia and you'd come in and now I just
finished a fucking route with Nate Marquardt.
Now I gotta go with kicked Jardeen cool.
Round three.
Yeah,
charge.
Didn't get out.
Jon Jones who come in and it's like,
what?
I mean,
the training you got there.
Correct.
Johnson's camp.
We're like,
well,
yeah,
I mean,
look,
there's a reason why so many extremely high level fighters are coming down
there.
And then Rashad Evans was there as well too.
And Rashad had a real problem with John Coming there because Rashad was like,
hey,
this guy's in my weight class,
but what are you going to do?
I have one guy,
he's way class.
Right.
It's an issue.
Yeah.
And then you know,
Rishad and John became friends.
They did fight.
Did they would,
yes,
they fought.
And John beat the shit out of him.
I don't even remember that they fought after they had a big falling out because
Rashad was upset that,
you know,
John Wound up,
John Wound up getting a title shot,
uh,
and beat Shogun because Rashad got injured.
Rashad was supposed to get the title shot,
John Steps in and they were friends at the time and then somewhere along the
line then the trash talk started,
you know,
I'll fight Rashad,
fuck it.
And then it was like,
man,
I thought we were friends and then,
oh yeah,
that's back when it was like,
you know,
you guys can fight as front and [inaudible].
You don't have to like be at enemies.
Everybody fight.
It's a sport and it's a money thing.
And then when John beat him,
it was a real drubbing and it was a five rounds.
It was a decision and uh,
it was a real clear cut,
unanimous decision.
He did some crazy shit to him.
Like step in elbow to the face.
I kind of do remember this one now.
This was John when he was developing John.
It wasn't even John,
like the John that knocked out DC.
I remember him when he sang it in fights.
I didn't really ever see this with the fighters where he would talk about after
wins,
talking about the holes,
the fuck ups he had more than the,
what he did right was most guys would be braggadocious,
but I loved it.
But it was like he was upset at things that went wrong.
Yeah,
I guess I got to cover that up.
That could get exposed.
You know,
John's a fucking smart dude.
I mean is reckless and chaotic as he is.
And you know,
I've said this before
that I don't know what causes that kind of recklessness,
but there is a direct correlation between traumatic brain injury,
brain damage and impulsive behavior and recklessness.
It's a fact.
It's well researched.
It's well documented in neuroscience.
They know that this,
this is a,
there's a connection.
I don't want to exonerate him from his past behavior,
but we see that in football players,
we see that in BMX riders that go crazy and fucking land on their head a bunch
of times.
People,
they get crazy,
they get wild and impulsive.
It's just a fact.
It's just a part of the game.
You know,
they,
those people that engage in any kind of an activity where you bring gets rattled
on a regular basis,
you are way more likely to do ridiculous things that don't make any sense.
Yeah,
it does.
And so what I said about John,
have you talked to John about it?
You know,
um,
and you know,
I know John was upset with me after one of those things before we actually did a
podcast together.
He was upset and I said,
listen man,
I have to be honest about everything.
I have to be honest about how I feel about every single aspect of your
performance,
of your behavior.
I have to be,
it doesn't mean I don't love you.
Doesn't mean I don't think you were great.
I hate to give your commentary on stuff.
I have to be,
you don't really choose sides.
I can't,
not only can I not choose sides,
I have to call what I see.
It's,
it's everything because if I don't,
then no one's going to listen to me.
There's just cause I have a comment on it.
Go ahead.
No,
go ahead.
Well,
I remember finding it interesting that after Brock beat heath herring,
yeah.
Um,
went to whatever steakhouse he wants to and heath coming in afterwards and
looking right at,
you said like it wasn't good.
He,
you were critical of him,
right?
He sought you out as I can.
I talk to you.
And it was like,
oh fuck,
he's mad.
But he's like,
he just wanted to express to you they had this leg injury and that's why he
couldn't really defend that takedown.
But it's interesting how the fighters that I get to see these fighters respect
your opinion enough to want to explain their side of it.
Well I appreciate it.
Um,
and there's always a side,
like what was talking about that fighter that has this pretty significant injury
that he's dealing with right now.
Like most people don't even know and they wouldn't have known if he didn't tell
you.
And there's a lot of these guys that go into fights and they're really
compromised.
You know,
they have hand injuries,
back injuries,
neck injuries.
And this is just a part of this crazy sport where you're,
the whole objective is to injure people.
So you're injuring each other in training and
when you got to hide those injuries,
cause then they'll exploit them.
Yeah.
But then there's the,
but this is why one of the reasons why I have to be honest all the time is
because people,
they respect the fact that I'm not going to,
I'm not saying things because it sounds cool.
I'm saying things because this is actually what I see and it maybe you have a
different perspective and maybe you could share your perspective with me and
I'll tell you why I thought this and maybe I'll change my mind
and I'm not scared to change my mind,
but we've got to say what I think.
Yeah.
And it's cool.
The fighters,
like I just said,
I wasn't being a pussy to see it.
I mean,
I would never think Keith haring would be a pussy care that you know,
the real truth of it.
Right.
And not that it was bad,
but like here's the reason.
It was interesting how they respect your opinion like that.
What guy?
Like Brock list or man,
I swear that if Brock Lesnar got into the,
into mixed martial arts right out of college when college wrestler right into
training,
really learned striking and learned slowly like took some small fight.
Jon Jones did.
Yeah.
And then,
but really learn striking instead of like spending all that time doing WWE,
which I'm sure he made a fuck load of money.
I mean good for him.
That's all great and everything like that.
But man,
I think he could have been one of the all time greats are really do a really
song.
Nobody,
nobody.
I remember cutting that much to heavyweight,
these giant,
but that was all weights would weigh in with their jeans on because they're
like,
all right,
whatever I am.
It was also,
there was no testing back then.
I know you've got to realize that the testing back then was horse shit.
And the way to be,
the best way to show the testing was horseshit was to show when Alistair Overeem
fought Brock.
That was the steroid Olympics,
those two guys together inside the octagon.
Uh,
but that was also Brock less than a year from diverticulitis surgery where they
had to remove I think 12 inches of his colon or is um,
well it was,
it's not even an immediate or I thought it was at the time then I talked to,
of all people,
Anthony Bordain told me now people get diverticulitis sometimes from seeds like
a,
it'll get stuck in your intestines.
So they had wrong.
Yeah,
well it's just things get caught and stuck.
Um,
but they,
they had to remove 12 inches of his intestines.
So that opened him
while he was,
and then he came back.
But he was done as,
as the Brock Lesnar that everybody feared.
Well,
he,
he says that he was compromised even before that.
He said he was compromised before the cane fight and before a lot of his other
fights,
even the fight with chain Carwyn from diverticulitis,
like who is suffering from it from a law for a long time.
And he just thought that,
you know,
it was just exhausted from training,
but really he was having this blockage and all this issue.
Look at this.
Jesus.
Yeah,
it was fun.
Talking to a as two 56 is incorrect.
By the way,
that's not true.
When he waited,
he was to 65.
If you look at it over him over,
he was over in was to 65 as well.
And if you look at ovary on the scale for that fight,
there's a,
there's,
that's a great picture of the two of them facing down like Jesus Christ or bolts
so jacked,
so big.
But it's not like there's six,
10.
When Overeem,
when Overeem was,
um,
was standing there flexing on the scale,
you know,
like what in the fuck is he on?
Like right there.
What the fuck dude?
Wow.
How he's not even like really fucking hard.
He's still smiling.
So Jack that he was so fuck,
what was Anderson's friends a trainer's name or manager's name to Paul Chek.
Gosh.
Oh,
oh,
I'm ed source.
That source.
Yeah.
And we were to ask him,
but like I bought the pride days.
He was like,
oh,
they tested for steroids and pride and you were like,
what?
They tested for steroids?
It goes,
yeah.
I mean,
they didn't do anything about it,
but they're just,
they're dusted with like get your both positive.
Go fight.
Who Cares?
Yeah.
Well,
according to ensign anyway.
Not only did they not test in pride,
they put it in the contract.
We do not test for steroids.
Oh,
I thought he said they tested it and then just like,
we don't give a shit,
but just want to know.
I think they test,
they took,
they took tests,
but they didn't really test you.
Damn.
Those guys are big ring card girl that she was so young.
Which one was that?
Oh,
he was a gold Barilla son.
Jesus.
It's blonde hair.
He should,
he should have been Nazi in the war that he's missed his call.
He would have been the one of the most feared Nazis there were.
Honestly,
if he was a fucking Nazi,
I would have rooted for the other team.
He was a viking Nazi's dude.
He would have been on one of them boats with a dragon on the front of it.
By the way,
I mean underrated Jon Jones for a weed head.
I mean,
yeah,
everybody gives all the credit to fucking Nate and nick fair.
They've earned it.
But when you would give a fuck at those breast strips,
half a strip was the dose.
That's right.
And on the plane.
And he was like,
how'd you got it?
What am I find?
His compliments was Jon Jones.
I heard somebody else goes,
hey,
you know John's always,
it always goes,
or just your fear.
It's always got great weed.
Yes.
Hell fucking yes.
I'll take that.
I gave him a package of breath strips and he ate the whole bag
is the dose.
He took two and you're like,
don't,
don't do that.
He's like,
Joe Rogan,
I'll be fine.
It was fine.
I was so scared for him.
I was paranoid because I gave Tommy buns a half and we flew to Florida.
And uh,
he told me,
he goes,
dude,
I swear to God when we landed,
he told,
he goes,
I didn't think I was gonna make it.
It was like one of those with you before.
I really thought,
I really thought I couldn't make it.
I really thought there's no way I'm going to be able to survive this flight.
I'm going to freak out.
I'm going to have them land somewhere.
I almost told the stewardess before he took off.
I was close to be like,
we're not doing,
we're not doing this before we were on the runway.
The only thing that stopped me from doing it is knowing the abuse I would have
taken from you verbally.
That's two years.
Then I'm like,
I'd rather die.
I love those days.
It was so fun.
I was actually,
I felt bad for you a couple of times in my life.
Why?
One time me and nick use,
if we're doing a corporate and Vegas and went to the new Aria and we took
edibles and we walked around and I was like,
oh,
Rogan's too famous and Bega,
he can't do this.
He can't get this fucked up and walk around,
but,
but watching the fights on edibles,
I'm like,
oh,
it's too bad.
You don't get to experience that.
Yeah,
you can't do that.
You can't have to do commentary 100% sober.
I tried early in the days,
early in the day.
I did like one or two events where I was a little fucked up and I was like,
this is just too cloudy.
I want to think cause I would want to talk about other shit.
Right.
The fight will be going on.
I want to talk about this thing.
Ray Tattoo on his back
and his last fights he was on there.
I think a guy who the fucking big black dude beat.
Okay.
Unless 13 seconds Volkov yeah,
I think he has a sting ray.
I thought it was like,
oh yeah.
It is kind of a sting,
right?
I could see you going like what a great fun.
Two stingers or some of the most underrated to creatures there are.
First of all,
they're peaceful.
Should have been involved in millions and millions of years.
We're strange thing to have tattoos on your back and wonder if he's like an
ocean guy.
It's really an
ice.
We swam with those.
Forget where.
Oh,
Flores.
Off of florists.
Really?
Yeah.
Near where the Komodo dragons are.
You fucking dive in.
And he went to the isle of Flores.
Oh,
that's,
that's where that little fucking man
lived.
You know,
they had that,
that human being that they found,
what do they call it?
Um,
Homo Floresiensis this,
I think they call it.
Yeah.
It was a little tiny hobbit,
like person that existed,
I want to say as recently as 10 to 15,000 years ago,
there was like a three foot tall kind of human.
Yeah.
There was,
there's been many different branches of human being,
right.
There's been neanderthals,
Homo Sapiens,
there's a one from Russia die in isis or something like that.
I forget how to say,
like,
look at that.
Oh yeah,
no,
I met that guy.
He ran a hostel.
I stood up.
Yeah.
That guy was the shit.
He gave me.
Good,
good drugs.
But this little little person that lived,
uh,
alongside human beings,
what,
see if my timeline is right.
They have speech they don't know,
but they know they use tools.
I don't know.
That always makes sure to paint them with tool to show you what,
95,000,
70,000 years ago.
Oh,
that's it.
17,000 years ago.
Wow.
Why does it say he bunked w what's that one?
Hobbit.
Human species debunked.
I don't think that's correct.
It says new historian,
but uh,
I'm pretty sure that's probably an old article or audiences.
What year?
What was that article?
When is that?
10 years ago.
10 years ago?
Yeah.
Was it 10 years ago?
2004 the talking about it.
I'm sorry,
so it's 2014 is the article that's fairly recently.
I don't think that's the consensus.
I don't think the consensus is that it's been debunked.
Tongue part is about the cranial volume or something.
Oh,
brain size,
but not that it was a separate species.
Cranium volume was calculated to be 430 million milliliters,
which puts it within the range of modern human living in the same region.
They went further comparing the size of the circumference of the Occipital,
said the word occipital frontal section of the skull to patients with
developmental disorders in that region.
The planet.
They found the measurements were indeed similar.
If lb one did have down syndrome,
then it would explain this short femurs as well.
Hence,
when calculated statistically for normal growth,
they would yield a height of just over four feet,
which matches up with some humans living on Flores.
Wow.
Hmm.
This is,
I think this is probably one of those heavily debated things,
but you're trying to recreate,
you know,
there's a thing called island dwarfism that happens too.
Um,
it's,
it's a really odd,
because it happens to mammals,
but the opposite takes place with lizards and reptile.
Massive.
Yeah.
Reptiles get massive like Komodo dragons on the island of Comodo.
Scariest giant.
They get huge.
They're their monitor lizards really,
essentially that are enormous.
Whereas elephants that live on islands get tiny.
They have these warf elephants.
Yeah.
See that island morphis room to have to cover,
so no less resources.
So they adapt to the taxes.
Less food.
Like,
look how tiny that elephant is that lives on those.
I mean,
it's an elephant that's like shorter than you.
Wow.
And Elephant.
It's through.
Yeah.
It's like,
that's like a elephant that's like my kid's height.
Like this is,
it happens with all sorts of different animals.
He Dwarf Buffalo.
Yeah.
Island dwarfism.
They think it's because these animals adapt to the fact that there's a limited
amount of living on a territory.
Right.
They don't have to cover long distances to get to something.
Yeah.
It's fucking crazy what happens with animals,
men when they figure out like what they need to do to survive.
Like one of the things that a I was reading about really recently was um,
these,
uh,
fuck,
I wish I had it off the top of my head,
but these moths that lived in a separate area,
an area where things were darker and they change from a light colored moth to a
black moth.
Like really quickly.
Really?
Yeah.
Like really quickly.
Like they did it over a couple of generations and they're trying to figure out
how the fuck this happened.
See if he could find that couple of generations peppered moth.
Yeah.
Really fast.
Like it,
it blew them away.
They don't understand how it happened so quickly.
I think there's like,
there's,
there's so little that's truly understood about what adaptive changes can
possibly happen within animals.
Like for instances is documentary called relentless enemies and it's all about
you're going to piss in something
we're going to use though.
Kombucha bottle.
Okay.
Where's the bottle?
Oh,
sorry.
I thought that was full.
It's the widest mouth.
Oh,
okay.
You know what you should do?
You should get one of those um,
ice bags that people use for.
Um,
definitely don't show that it will get kicked off of Youtube.
There's a ice bags that um,
people use like compression ice bags and they have like a nice wide mouth.
Oh,
that's cool.
I had some of them here,
but I don't want to give it to God.
Dammit.
That's listening in it.
It didn't work so much.
Piss through.
Much piss.
Okay.
What else do we got?
Nothing.
Top ones off the topping it off.
I'll use this.
Why don't you just run off to the bathroom real quick and just hold onto your
deck and scared.
Jeff,
why don't you just suck it?
I don't think I want to do that.
Don't piss in that cup please.
What do you got?
What's that other of Tumbler?
Yeah,
go ahead.
Pissing that could,
I don't know what that's for.
Definitely take the piss out of here though afterwards.
You don't want it with me.
I'm like a wasted
pieces with it.
That's the thing is I bet you could sell that bit in and out.
That's like the pissed it was Andrea roads.
This is Ari.
Shaffir is piss for real on episode two was 47.
It was witchcraft.
Alright.
Give it a shake and let's get back to you.
Okay.
All right.
Jamie's turned his head away.
He's afraid of Dicks.
Trying to be,
don't be afraid.
The glory.
No.
Uh,
I believe this might be actually,
yeah.
Yeah,
they are.
How fucking comfortable with those.
The best.
The only one of the,
only two,
maybe them and blue apron and the only like no longer sponsors that I'm like,
I'll still rep your guys.
What's going on with you and sponsors?
Did,
did something happen when you said something crazy but a sponsor and they give
you a hard time.
Yeah,
man.
Get recruiter.
Was that what it was?
Yeah.
It's okay.
I get it.
I'm not for everybody,
but then it's like we're,
we can't work together anymore.
Yeah.
I just,
I can't operate under the idea that you can tell him what to say.
What'd they say?
Don't say something they said it's offensive.
When I'm like,
what did you say it?
I think it was something along the lines of like a,
if you're a human resources person and you have to a higher,
you can,
your time can be spent better,
you know,
doing something else.
You could fucking quickly hire somebody,
used Zipcar,
and then spend all your time masturbating in your office.
You can bring in like a Ziploc bag and keep putting like use socks in there that
you masturbated into.
I don't know.
I'm just going off top of my head trying to be funny.
It's pretty reasonable.
Three minute read on a one minute by yeah.
And then they're like,
it's offensive.
Like that's fine.
All right.
But I can't be thinking about it.
I refuse to let myself think about,
so I'll just give up the money.
Yeah.
I've had some people get pissed at me.
And it's fair on their part.
I get it.
I don't agree,
but I get it.
That's your,
that's your right.
Some of our Vistage is language.
Yeah,
exactly.
But I'm like,
that's not the way I'm going to do it,
so we're done.
It's such a foolhardy way of looking.
I believe that too.
I believe a good sponsor read that one I did was to Gora for stock,
but beds where I was like,
he ain't getting pegged in the ass by Christine,
Christina and a,
and he's fucking bleeding,
but his knees are Oh,
so soft and the Saatva mattress.
It's like,
dude,
man,
they got Super Mad.
They're going to go back in and edit and take it down.
Which I'm like,
no,
you're giving me more work to not pay me.
He said,
take it down.
Yeah,
so I had to go reedit well,
why?
Why do they have the right to say take it down?
Because they're like,
come on,
we're a family company.
I'm like,
dude,
my listeners aren't family.
I'm the Ra.
She fears can exactly.
Family Company.
Exactly and I'm like,
guys,
I can give you gold once in a while if you let me be fully free,
I can give you something that got passed around a,
I remember Berg up naturebox pissed at him.
He goes,
it's fucking healthy.
Hey,
hey,
have a fucking
apple.
Yeah,
why do you want to eat healthy?
Well that goes against like,
I won't shit on the actual products.
He couldn't help it.
They gave him the copy and it's like the healthiest snacks.
He doesn't preread it.
He just reads.
It strikes bullshit with them and you're like,
Nah,
I don't know.
I know we're done.
Well,
there are some like irrefutable sponsors,
like for me,
Squarespace irrefutable,
awesome product,
but they always let me go do whatever I want.
Whatever the fuck you mean.
Andy's,
if I started saying I wear me on,
these are super credible.
Also when you have that last bit of calm on your Dick,
it'll soak them up perfectly.
They,
they'd be like,
whatever.
They don't care.
They're not saying,
how dare you.
I'll be like,
hey,
the get the dark ones that cover up the fucking blood.
That comes out of your house really well,
they'd be like,
Oh,
you're not shitting on the product.
You're not saying it's uncomfortable.
So go ahead.
Yeah.
So super corporate guys,
the ones that zip recruiter or that kind of shit.
Yeah,
yeah,
I guess.
And it's like,
it's fine.
It's just signs.
Yeah.
I make money by continuously focusing on free speech and I'll lose money in some
spots and makes money and other spots and this is all just part of it.
Yeah.
You can't really think about it like only looking to make money every time.
Make more cause that universal growth paradigm,
you know,
that's only for corporations and then I'm going to be doing straight ad reads
and my listeners can get bored as fuck.
I'm going to lose listeners.
So then I'll be able to make less money off ads in the long run because of that
more as less money as opposed to like fewer ads more.
It's like,
well not only that,
it's like how much time do we really have left?
Yeah.
If we,
if both of us live another 45 years,
would it be fucking amazing?
Yeah.
That's 45 seasons of sober October's,
you know,
that would be amazing.
Oh No.
Two 45 the less sober October done.
I shouldn't have gotten roped into this one.
Are you done because of the contest?
Are you done because of the sobriety.
So what can we do in January?
Why January?
So October is the best drinking month in New York.
We could definitely do it in January,
but w w New Year's Eve.
Oh yeah.
Or February even.
Yeah,
because technically after midnight you'd still be fucked up and you would never,
I wouldn't mind November.
Yeah.
No booze.
November.
What?
He buttoned thanksgiving.
You have a little Turkey.
You want a nice,
I honestly though Thanksgiving,
the memories.
You have a thanksgiving.
We'll childhood.
They're not alcohol based?
No,
not really.
You might want something,
but that's what she really wants.
If you said no stuffing,
he'd be like,
hold on.
That's part of it.
But no alcohol and Thanksgiving,
that's not a big deal.
What about March?
March is okay.
More sober march.
Sure.
That's hard to bullshit.
Month.
The fuck goes on in March.
March is a bullshit month.
March madness.
St Patrick's Day.
Saint Patrick's Day is March.
Yeah,
it is.
Yeah.
But yeah,
but I'm not Irish.
I'm barely Irish.
Quarter Irish spring big.
Well guess what we're in.
We don't have that anymore.
You've got to go whatever.
There's always a reason by October is a one of them.
All the Nyu kids have calmed down and going to classes.
So like you can actually,
the cities back two years again.
It's amazing.
And it's like,
it's fucking hard.
I just,
I passed my bars.
I'm like,
I want to fucking go.
I want to go with Jay and be like,
let's go to fucking neighborhood bar.
It's fucking awful.
Couple of days away,
buddy.
We're only 10 days left now.
It's just,
what's really important is that we beat Bert.
I for sure.
I don't care if you win.
I don't care if Tom Quinn,
as long as Bert loses as long as Britain users.
Can I,
um,
can I tell you,
can we talk about drugs at the UFC for a little bit?
Sure.
So with Diaz always bringing the breath strips there be this time where it
wouldn't kick in,
it wouldn't kick it.
And you look over like feeling it.
You'd be like,
ah,
maybe sort of or,
or one of those jolly ranchers that they'd have.
I remember having a side,
I remember eating a jolly rancher like before the fight started because I would
get an answer early with you.
And I'm kind shocking.
I'm like the US and some other guy.
Nobody knew me back then and it was like,
dude,
I think somebody's smoking weed or look,
no,
we come from,
from home and he smelled the weed from the jolly ranchers.
Yeah.
And nobody could comprehend back then that it could be coming from your jolly
rancher.
It's Olay from smokeable 2003.
Um,
and then you look over,
you're feeling it sort of,
and then you look over again.
And Diaz just like in a trance when you realized you are too,
and you both look and Diego
and you know,
he bought the devil in.
Yeah.
And it was just fucking great.
And that's,
I mean,
I've talked about something,
this is not happening.
Stories where it's like you don't even know who's winning fights.
You just know you're enjoying watching them.
Acid,
one of the UFC events.
Yeah.
Back when we were sitting with kill scene and,
and uh,
we didn't tell him red band new and just do an acid.
I remember how low,
how into it you were,
that part of me is you never quite know how people can react to things.
So you really know them.
And like it could have gone like it was my place of work.
You can't,
you know,
a small part of me thinks maybe,
but then you're texting us while you're in the fights where all you guys,
where are you got to sit?
And it wasn't one of those,
we got bottom floor,
we're in the fucking stands for that one.
And we kept looking at us until you found us.
Like Dan's every I like you're doing as a great,
Oh man,
I've never saw see stuff so clearly.
I remember Forrest Griffin coming in with a shipping up to Boston playing and
everyone cheering.
And I was like,
this is the Colosseum.
We're watching what it was like in the coliseum for a few people fighting lions.
This is the,
everyone's cheering for blood.
How are we different than the Romans?
Pretty fucking similar in a lot of ways.
Yeah.
Just a modern,
more acceptable version of it.
Oh,
that acid that you have seen with so fucking good.
It was great.
He didn't want any food.
Red Bank sorta took care of you a little bit.
He was like,
oh,
I'll have some of the fucking auntie Dolores cookies.
Yeah,
we've done,
I mean,
I went to a bunch of events outside of the UFC where we got really fucked up on
Adam went to that one and a at the playboy mansion Strikeforce.
Yeah,
we got,
we got fucked on those.
Blasted in that one.
Yeah.
That was,
I missed out
on a lot of that.
Like you guys sitting there in the audience had a lot more fun than
six hours of fucking greatness.
So you take him early and by the very end it's like you're just coming down
enough to like,
let's go eat these dykes,
Joe Rogan's.
Buying again,
let's go.
Ah,
there was one in Calgary where it fell on shrimp fest and it was with Duncan and
I was like,
Hey,
I got as mushrooms,
and he goes,
oh,
I don't,
I don't want to come.
I don't want to take mushrooms right now.
And I was like,
okay,
I'll just throw them out.
I'll have to get the mushrooms I have for you.
I'll throw them out,
I'll step on them on the ground and throw them out.
So he went to,
he goes,
all right,
relax.
I'll take them off.
And Man,
it's so fun there because like you would take them,
you get bored,
there's some wrestling fight,
you know,
where it's like they're trying to outpoint each other and you're like,
let's go wander.
And you just go wander.
You could get a hot dog.
We put him into a Maynard's,
which is like jolly rancher,
like,
like gummy,
whatever.
We'd stick them in there so you could reach farther and Maynard or you reach in
there and you feel something crunchy like a stick and you're like,
okay,
I'm going for that.
We just keep eating these mushrooms.
Some random dudes were like,
hey,
you want to come fucking to our skybox?
And so we went to some skybox for awhile until we got kicked out by security and
that was fun.
Like there's go as we were great fucking giant pupils.
I saw a fucking security guard in Calgary as we were going in and already
tripping and trying to smuggle these,
these mushrooms in there and this guy goes,
hey man,
happy shroom fest.
And I was like,
oh,
okay.
You're being cool about it.
Like you know about it and you're letting me go like thank you very much.
Security officer.
I knew about shrooms was like a cop,
one of those that they hire there.
It kind of,
Calgary was fun.
Calgary's great,
great city.
Yeah,
doing,
doing that during the edibles.
I remember Alex Jones being there once in d has given him a cookie and it goes
right.
He goes,
hey,
this cookie.
Yeah.
And Alex Jones is like,
what's in the cookie?
And Diaz eat the fucking cookie.
Like,
like what kind of stupid question is that?
You know what's in there?
We went to eat with him afterwards.
He was barbecued barbecue,
much more reasonable back then.
I never,
I never understood how they made him from crazy conspiracy theorists to alter
[inaudible].
I didn't get the connection there.
Well
that connection happened when he became United with like Alex Jones became
United with Donald Trump.
Right?
Like,
cause he was a big part of Donald Trump in,
in the campaign days,
Donald Trump would call in,
he would call into info wars and he knew that Alex Jones had a big base and Alex
Jones would help them get elected.
You know,
Donald Trump,
it's very clever.
And who he aligns himself with.
Like when you see him standing there listening to Kanye West,
what Kanye West is ranting and saying all this crazy fucking skitzo nonsense and
he's like this,
hmm.
That's a smart cookie.
He's very smart.
And when he calls bullshit and when he doesn't call bullshit,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
It's like,
imagine if Kanye West was debating him and they were doing a presidential debate
and Kanye was talking like that.
It'd be like,
what the fuck is this guy saying?
What are you saying?
Give enough for me so I'll let you talk.
Yeah,
he's,
you know,
I just don't get how stones what it was because he would have him on a bunch.
Well,
you know,
also out outright wasn't a thing back then.
You got to realize when,
when Alex came with us to,
to the fights,
that was no outright,
but he was more like lizard.
People are like are like,
oh,
it's a fucking government conspiracy.
Yeah.
He was all about don't get him started on nine 11 it's like he was all about
certain conspiracies.
I remember we were in Austin once when there was a shooting at a,
at an army base.
We were there right with him.
When the thing went out about and we were at a bar that goes,
I guarantee you they're not taking that guy alive.
I guarantee they won't let him talk.
And then an hour later,
like they got them alive,
the shot him in the leg or they got them alive because yeah,
of course it got him a lot because they want them to be a fucking martyr for
this thing and it's like or whatever.
It's going to be Marta,
right?
Yeah.
And it's like no matter what,
he's just,
I'm spinning this to conspiracy and then I just,
that business is a tricky business.
I just don't,
I don't think I said like,
no,
you've got to be off the air now.
And it's like,
well that's where it's fucked up.
It just elicit person guy.
Well it's not though,
because like people were concerned that you're giving out bad information.
Right.
And they're concerned about it.
But then with Alex,
what came out was the sandy hook thing,
the Sandy Hook denial thing.
It was when again,
conspiracy,
I don't get why that's right.
But it was a conspiracy involving children being murdered and their parents
being actors.
And then everyone was like some sort of a crisis actor and they were hired by
the government to take away people's guns.
This is,
this is the most radical version of shirts.
I understand and I understand that that's wrong and crazy.
Where do you get from there to,
you can't be allowed to say these crazy.
You've been saying these made up things before,
right?
You're saying it's still,
what's a free,
I don't get why it's a hate monger.
You got a really good argument.
But here's the argument.
The argument is what is Facebook?
What is Twitter?
What is Youtube?
Are they private companies?
Mercer,
most certainly,
or even more so are they utilities?
Is it like the electricity?
Is it like a phone?
Like what should you be allowed to tell someone?
They can't use it?
Like I wonder if Jack said,
Hey,
I'm shutting down Twitter.
If the government is like,
we're opening it back up again.
Right?
Or is it like NBC?
Cause if NBC is a private company and Ari Shaffir says,
Hey,
the lizard people are eating kids and that's,
that's death to run 60 minutes.
And they say,
no,
our,
you're fired.
Like Bro,
Zan made one fucking bad ambien joke and they canceled her.
They kicked her off of,
uh,
for,
for any other reason.
They were,
they weren't,
that's not true.
Why do you say that show was a huge hit?
Because of the outrage over the first season when she was like,
she supports Trump.
Yeah,
but there was a giant hit,
but they were looking to get rid of her at this whole group was already saying,
we want you out.
We're looking for an excuse.
Kind of like when they got rid of you at the comedy store over filming,
when it was like,
come on.
They already wanted to get rid of you.
Well,
and then they found an excuse to get it done.
That's a tricky argument because they wanted her so bad.
They wanted her out.
I think they wanted to minimize her paid.
That's true.
But she was telling me how they were changing the way they were writing things
and they weren't including her in the process where she was very much included
in the process during the first season when they were writing for the second
season.
They were there basically excluding her from the process of premises and the way
they were writing the show.
I mean,
I read,
I read all the outrage about early on it was like,
you're a Trump supporter.
And I read,
I saw someone like Ray Sani,
some young female comedian going like it when,
when,
when Silverman was like,
Hey,
watch my friends show Rosanne.
She's great,
great show.
And she goes,
no,
this is the bitch I got to be fake with at a party and kissed her on the cheek,
pretend I'm cool with her.
And it's like,
what is all this outrage over this pro Trump thing?
And I finally,
I'm like,
let me go watch it.
And my friend,
Jewish female leftist Morgan Murphy who wrote it,
uh,
I talked to her later about it,
but I finally watched it.
And it's this 12 characters in the show,
10 of them don't talk about who they voted for it all.
One of them is pro Trump,
anti Trump.
It's also a little trans kid on there and that's it.
Just one pro Trump,
one anti anti-Trump and the outrage dies.
Saw was almost like,
I don't think you guys could've possibly watch this episode.
I think you're all reading headlines about stories.
And that's what I talked to Morgan about it.
I'm like,
it doesn't seem like it could have come from the actual facts,
you know,
there was a lot of that going on.
Right?
Yeah.
And so I,
I feel like it's the same thing with Alex Jones.
I'm going hate monitor.
I'm like,
what?
Alex Jones,
just crazy conspiracy guy.
Most of it.
Yeah.
Most of the hate monger.
Well,
yeah.
Um,
do you talk about taking away trans rights or anything like that?
Doing some talk?
There was some talk Alex Jones was saying and one of the,
one of the last final straws,
it was talking about people taking up arms and that people are not going to
stand it.
And you know,
it's,
it's basically rabble rousing,
which is like a lot of what people do when they're there talking about the other
side,
trying to take away your rights,
trying to take away your guns.
We're not gonna stand for it.
You know,
you know people are going to get shot,
you know that kind of talk.
I mean,
I don't know specifically what he said,
but this is a problem that you don't know specifically.
Right.
There's a problem that they can just decide that you represent a certain faction
of thought and that this should be eliminated from,
you should be deep platformed instead like the platform for a conspiracy guy and
they go,
people are going up to those those parents and saying like your kid's not dead.
And it's like a real issue.
Yeah,
but it's like he's not calling for that.
That's what they're doing on their own.
Somebody shot two cops in New York because of the black lives matter movement.
You don't shut down the black lives matter movement over that.
They weren't asking for them to shoot cops.
Someone did on their own who was also an,
he was an avenue to do that,
right?
No,
he wasn't.
So like,
so like I don't see how you deep plat for the only great article I read was by a
trans woman who said,
when I hear crazy shit like that,
I feel like it's supposed to roll your eyes and then walk away.
You don't say,
Hey,
you need to get gone.
Well,
you know,
d platforming people,
that's a good way to put it,
dad.
That is what they're saying.
And it's also,
it seemed like it was a universal d platforming because Twitter was the one of
the last places that kept him on.
And then they decided that they were going to remove him,
but I didn't see anything specifically.
Cause yeah,
I like,
they have some rules like that when they got,
um,
who's a woman that was Rose McGowan and then she was claim talking about a rape
and people are like,
how dare you,
she,
she out of the rape and then,
and then a u d platform or from Matt or you just took it out from that?
Um,
and that was the story.
That was a headline.
Everyone's like,
how dare you Jack,
is that the guy from Twitter?
Jack Dorsey?
Yeah.
How dare you.
And then he actually responded.
He goes,
oh no,
no,
no.
She docked somebody's,
she gave somebody information about where they live and stuff like that.
And that's,
we already had that role.
You can't do that.
Right?
Nothing to do with why she dox them.
Well,
let's,
let's just over that,
why don't you Google what exactly got Alex Jones kicked off Twitter?
Cause he would,
Twitter was one of the last platforms and then they can say hate speech and hate
speech is one of those weird,
broad,
broad terms.
It's like I hate you.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
I mean I,
I really am like,
I don't,
I think people are forgetting how the ACL you defended the Klan members because
the free speech is too big.
Uh,
uh,
a fucking issue to worry about how I feel about what they're saying.
Well,
you know what's really interesting is that left leaning people,
the leftists are the ones that want to censor and d platform and silence people
on the right.
It is.
It's also both.
I think we see the left more cause word,
that bubble.
I think it goes the right is doing it.
So we just don't,
we're not friends with her.
The white doing it.
They have no,
no power in technology that the tech companies,
whether it's Facebook,
Google,
Twitter,
they're all left.
Yeah.
And they're the ones who have the mean.
This is where it's weird.
Right.
It's because nobody saw this coming.
It was media.
Like you had Fox News,
you had NBC,
you had,
you had your left and you had your right.
More left than right of sure.
But there was power in the Fox News,
you know,
faction,
they had their voice.
But in the,
in,
when it comes to technology,
there's not really an equivalent or commensurate company.
It's all left.
Yeah.
There's not one right leaning large social media platform.
Right.
They don't exist.
It should just stay out of it.
But,
but I,
I get why they,
you're getting,
you gotta read it situation where it's like,
okay,
but suddenly it devolved into just child porn will read it.
The problem with Reddit is an anonymity when you give people anonymity and one
guy actually lost his job because of it because somebody decided,
hey,
this guy is such a fucking creep piece of shit.
Let's find out who the fuck he is.
And he got his Ip and then they figured out who he was and then he was like some
guy who is a dad,
right?
It was like some regular guy with a job and they got him fire and like,
you know,
he had a bunch of weird,
kid fucking type posts and
a bunch of shit that just people,
it's almost like role playing where it's like you're not serious.
Exactly.
And it's all said [inaudible] people were running out of the room yesterday or
two days ago.
He got a full room randomly the end of the night.
Yeah.
He spent his first three minutes like,
oh,
it's cable.
Oh No,
it's due.
I never got up out of this many people,
like he couldn't handle it.
And then he starts going,
they start leaving and he starts getting angry and born to his pocket,
you know,
into where he's belongs.
And that asks people to leave in like he's talking about child fucking and stuff
like that.
And uh,
and um,
it was a peek behind the curtain.
I didn't fuck a baby,
just so you know,
there were no babies fucked.
So calm down.
Well,
people don't want to hear about that subject and that's fair.
That's to the comedy store.
Do your some wonderful jokes about people losing socks in the dryer.
Right?
So actually,
honestly walking out,
is it fine response?
Yeah.
Saying he can't go up anymore.
It's not a fine response response and saying you're going to boycott the comedy
store because they don't do your kind of comedy and you,
if you want to boycott.
And that's also okay.
But yeah,
just trying to get other people to
all right.
All right.
But there's that,
this is a problem in that there's no balance,
right?
If people are just right leaning and people want a deep plat form them because
they have right-leaning beliefs,
right.
Leaning ideas like say if they support president Trump,
I mean he is the president.
Whether you like it,
you're allowed to like it or not.
You want whether you like it or not,
that guy's the president and when do you like his policies or not?
They are his policies.
He's the president of the United States and if someone supports that deep
platforming people who support him and support that is not the right response.
The right response is a well-worded argument against that is against that.
That is convincingly articulate to the point where you,
you make an argument that this is a terrible policy,
a terrible idea and an objective fence rider like myself that watches that and
reads it might go,
okay,
this guy's got a good point.
Yeah,
I want to hear both sides,
but I need to hear that side in order to hear the alternative side,
like Dave Smith who hates all politicians,
pretty much,
he was pointing out these like separating their kids from their parents thing
and he's like,
it's gotten real bad with Trump now.
And he goes,
okay,
that's true.
But look at the picture they're using on the bottom right hand corner.
There's a date stamp on it and it's 2014 yeah,
there's definitely a lot of shenanigans.
So like your,
your anger is not even who,
I can't even bring that up.
Elysium the what that is and,
and online journalism look,
journalism my fucking fighting for their lives right down back there.
And it's terrible.
It's terrible.
And it's also,
there's no money in it.
There's a problem is nobody wants to buy newspapers and we want to buy magazines
and it's really hard for online journalism to not resort clicktale anger shit.
Yeah.
I mean that's literally how they make their living now as click bait shit.
And so,
you know,
they have a photo.
This is what the stock photo.
We got a little fucking kid who's crying and he's standing in front of a border
patrol guy,
throw it up,
use it is what we got the stories real.
The photo's not,
it's it's Shit Journal.
I think it really comes down to like when you see like a norm McDonald where
it's like,
okay,
I haven't done anything to anybody wrong.
I just want to look at with compassionate and other human.
I'm like,
these are p,
there's a friends of mine.
The people I know.
What do you mean?
Just be specific what you're saying about norm Macdonald.
He said like Roseanne and Louie and like they'd lost everything in a day and
people don't really understand what it's like.
Right.
And I would like to see these friends,
human beings,
friends of mine come up with a way and he goes,
honestly,
I don't think Rosanne who that lady was black.
I don't think she makes that comment.
And then people go,
fuck you.
You're can't.
Your tonight show appearance is canceled.
And it's like,
why do you even do anything?
When we tell him he didn't do anything,
instead of taking that opportunity to go,
hey,
let's hear him out.
Maybe you can clarify what you mean,
right?
Even say,
no,
I didn't mean it that way.
The platform,
the platform,
cause he's women or people,
I don't really know who they were at the tonight show had their opportunity to
fall on their sword and they go,
now we get to stand up for women's rights and we get to stand up for racial
rights instead of going like,
let's have him on,
have him on and say,
Jimmy Fallon go,
what?
What did you mean by that?
Exactly.
And then to clarify his position to now show,
Oh,
I'm on your side,
but people don't want that.
They're more interested.
They're more interested in punishment.
And so now you're punishing people who are on your side so you can feel right at
the comedy cellar.
A waitress was traveling to fucking work,
wearing her comedy cell,
a t shirt off to Louis came back and somebody said,
hey,
headphones,
like take your headphones out.
And she did.
She goes,
what?
And they go,
shame on you.
To some waitress who by the way,
he's not in charge of him coming back.
She might've actually guy or girl that said shame on you don't know.
I think a woman,
I'm not sure,
but this waitress might've been like heavily against him coming back,
but there's no research done.
It's just like,
I get my chance to show that I've stuck up for somebody instead of ruining some
other woman's Day who might be on your side.
Yeah.
Well this is one of the stuck a finger in Val's face after he came back.
Fuck you.
After they were leaving,
that was one of the managers of the seller.
And it's like,
so here's a fellow woman who hasn't done anything wrong.
Right.
And you're,
you're,
you're cursing her out so you can feel like I've done something for the cause.
Yeah.
Well this is,
no,
the left does that.
The right doesn't do the left attacks its own.
Yeah.
And they,
they attack.
Tina Fey once said,
your antifeminist and she was like,
you're out of your fucking mind about what,
five,
six years ago,
I don't remember.
And she goes,
you out of your mind.
I'm your leader,
I'm on your side.
You're attacking me for being antifeminist.
You're out of your fucking mind.
They eat their own.
They can't.
They have blood loss and they know how to control it.
You're not trained in fucking fighting.
Well,
they're always looking for targets.
They're always looking for targets and in finding and establishing a target,
you clearly establish that you are better and more virtuous than that person.
Right?
Because you find a fence in something that they do.
They're not progressive enough and they are a part of the problem.
And so he cast them out or you shut them down or you d platform.
Yeah,
so I think with Alex Jones,
they go,
hey,
they pointed to that one a lot.
They're like,
dude,
he said fucking Sandy Hook didn't happen.
And it's like,
okay,
I'm not,
I'm not saying I'm not.
You've tried it.
Now I get Straw man me into saying,
I'm saying,
that's okay or that's right.
I'm not saying this right.
I just don't see the connection to this.
I don't see the connection to Michael Vick killing dogs,
which I'm not in the side of too.
You shouldn't play football.
Right.
You haven't made that connection to me and be like,
Oh,
you're saying it's okay to kill dogs?
Like no,
it's just why is that job not allowed?
Yeah.
The connection would be if you have a private company,
this is where we're,
we're all boils down to like,
do you have a right to use their platform so you're not taking Alex Jones off
the Internet.
Right.
Alex Jones still has this website in the Internet,
but if you have,
uh,
if Ari should fear.com all the sudden becomes Twitter.
Okay.
There's,
there's a separate thing though.
Private company,
are they allowed and it's private company.
Should you be doing that?
Should you be doing with the laws are,
I agree with only a portion of it.
The laws,
you know,
this is in response to like the cockpit type of shit that has happened at reddit
that reddit has gotten so fucking out there in so many different ways and so
like that,
especially the Trump section of reddit.
Yeah.
Like people let them be there.
They're not doing anything to anybody.
They're not planning attacks.
But people who,
if you save,
you own that company and you were one of the people that was responsible for
trying to sell ads for Twitter or for whatever.
I don't think Twitter has ads,
but if you had like established guidelines,
which you could and couldn't say,
one of those things would probably be no hate speech,
no racism,
no this,
no that.
But you can't promote false conspiracy theories that hurt other people.
Right.
That you,
you could get away with saying that.
Right?
So it's not about,
so it's kind of like the,
the,
the Rose McGowan thing where it's like,
oh no,
it's not about,
you just can't talk to anybody.
What does this,
Jamie,
this is from a NPR interview with a Washington Post reporter about why,
what's read this?
It says,
and when I spoke to somebody at Twitter,
they said one thing that weighed very heavily on them was the way that Jones
conducted himself outside of a congressional hearing where Twitter CEO,
Jack Dorsey,
was testifying about the way the company moderates content online.
Jones.
Specif essentially went after Republicans,
Senator Mark Marco Rubio interrupted one of his press conferences.
He yelled at Dorsey at one point as he was trying to leave the building and then
he live streamed the incident where he was attacking a CNN reporter,
hurling verbal insults at him.
The video was broadcast on periscope,
which is the live streaming site owned by Twitter and so in the minds of the
company and essentially was too much.
He had gone too far and so they kicked him off the site.
Yeah,
I mean I guess if you're talking about you're right.
It's like,
sure,
I guess it's their right,
but I disagree with them doing it.
I would,
I would like a world where you were like,
we don't,
unless it's physical harm to someone,
possibly monetary,
like direct monetary harm,
like I'm stealing from you.
It infringes on your rights then do what you want.
Say what you want.
Right.
It doesn't infringe on your rights and keep going.
Well,
the problem he comes who's to decide what is hate speech.
Exactly.
Who we don't decide that and who is to decide.
Is it saying retard in a Thompson Gora special hate speech?
It's,
it's,
it's such a slippery slope that the only way to do it is if you infringe on
someone's right,
you've gone too far because you haven't,
you have not yelling fire in a crowded theater.
Yeah.
It's,
it's free speech until you,
like someone is going to get,
is getting hurt from this or it's very possible that they will,
you can see why they would not just like it might hurt their feelings.
Am I making it harder for them to,
to,
to be a kid in this world?
It's like no.
Yeah,
no,
I agree.
But I also agree that if you,
or NBC or ABC or CBS and someone says things that you feel violate your
company's policies,
right?
So if someone promotes some outlandish conspiracy theory about children that
gets shot in Parkland really never died.
And their parents are all crisis actors paid by the CIA.
It's a psy op and you know,
this person is on CBS,
you can fire them right now.
Worries the question.
But let me finish here.
So is Twitter like CBS Ppas,
they're both private companies.
And are the people who are on broadcasting on periscope and on Youtube,
are they essentially someone who is,
I mean you kind of,
are you working with or for Youtube if you're broadcasting on Youtube?
I mean,
how do you look at it?
I don't think so.
I think it's a private thing.
And I think,
I think if you're making a video on how to make a bomb,
um,
I think the authority should get in there,
right?
So you can't do that.
But what if you making a video about how there's some people out there that are
lying about their children being shot?
Same thing.
Got The authorities.
Then if you think it's leading to harm,
but it's not the company,
so you don't do it,
you should be allowed.
If your youtube,
you don't think you should be allowed to tell someone,
hey,
you say a bunch of shit,
that's not true and it hurts people.
What's your,
what's the word?
Hurt me.
Well.
Okay,
if your children were murdered and there's some guy screaming on youtube that
you're a crisis actor and nothing ever happened to your kid and your kids,
it's a lie.
And there's rubber kids in the ground with fake blood and they can prove it with
the Hologram.
You shouldn't be able to remove them from your,
to your platform.
Do you remember,
um,
what's his name from?
And by the way,
I'm not arguing by now.
And the other is important for people online to understand.
This is the Kansas Pastor,
what's his name?
He died Kansas Pastor,
which we talked on the radio once that not just church,
something Baptist Church.
And he would go to funerals of,
of uh,
oh,
Phelps.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And he would go there and say,
the reason your son died is because gays around.
Yeah.
And he ruined people's funerals.
So much have a child who died.
My wife bags.com and not,
and these weren't gay soldiers were just soldiers.
Right?
It's horrible.
And then other people had to do things like create a blockade around their cars
and say,
give us tickets.
We'll eventually move,
but the funeral will be over.
Yeah,
man,
that's sucky behavior.
You can't stop them from doing it.
Okay.
You so,
okay,
so go to CME terms of public discourse.
So go to CBS and say that and say like,
well,
we can take you down because you've said things that are totally untrue.
What about the guy who gets caught smoking weed in,
uh,
I was a legal state and I'm in Alabama.
Could you fire from that?
Yeah,
but that's a different thing.
It goes against what we think is okay.
That's a slippery slope.
I mean,
if you're saying,
are you allowed legally?
Yes,
of course.
But morally,
no.
I think you,
you're a fucking platform for speech.
So let all the speech in.
Mm.
And four Chan got written up as this fucking hateful place.
We're really,
they're just trolls.
And they know one of the best ways to troll is using Donald Trump.
Well,
you know,
there was a really interesting case with four Chan that I found preposterous
where they trolled Sheil booth.
Oh yeah.
They took down that,
that podcast.
Yes.
We tell us it was great.
It was great.
It was hilarious.
And people go,
how dare you promote four Chan,
they're a hate group.
And you're like,
you didn't listen.
We've just said that they're not a hate group.
And you're like,
fuck you,
I don't like that interpretation.
Fuck you.
Norm Macdonald's.
I liked the interpretation.
She did know that lady was black.
Okay.
You went real far with that.
But you can't say Rosanne wasn't racist.
I,
he's like,
he's not saying racism is okay.
He goes,
we're Norma sang.
I don't think she was new.
That lady was black.
I agree with four.
Chan is not saying pro Trump.
Fuck all of you pro Trump at fortune is saying this will fuck with you.
Let's fuck with you.
Well they're saying fuck Shiela booth cause he's,
he's a goof and they decided to use science and they literally,
they,
they studied the stars in the sky.
Oh it was amazing.
Amazing troll had someone drive around and beeped their horn so they could
triangulate the area where this has taken me where the airplanes were going over
ahead.
Took the FA.
Yeah.
Took the fucking flag down and went,
Fuck Shiloh of the day.
They found it somewhere in the world and the podcast was great and there was no
hate involve.
It had nothing to do with political ideology,
had nothing to do with racism and nothing to do with hate.
And people were saying,
Oh,
you're supporting you dope was fortunate.
Supports Hitler.
Now listen,
four Chan is just a bunch of people and it's like,
yeah,
they've just said in that podcast a fortunate does not support littler.
Yeah,
they go Trump,
Trumbull,
fuck with people.
Let's align that with some fucking weird fraud for no reason.
It makes no sense.
Right.
And that's now explained to me where that frog thing came from and I'm like,
Oh,
you're just pulled a random thing out.
Well most of that frog thing was fun.
It was fun.
Yeah.
And there was a few instances of that frog,
which were racist or KKK versions or Nazi versions.
And then people decided that whole frog racist.
But he's all over in Geneva as a good luck sign.
Different different case.
The vast majority of the use of that frog was not racist.
The vast majority was,
feels bad,
man.
Yeah.
It was silly trolling.
It was just being silly.
Yeah.
And then there was like,
you can't let people coopt a frog,
you know,
NPR,
I think it was NPR podcasts.
It might've been,
I'm not sure what the company was.
They were like,
yeah,
we'll take it down.
You can still have it.
It's still on Radiolab.
Radiolab.
Okay.
Yeah.
And they're like,
sorry about that.
We'll take it out on youtube.
I just heard it.
Well,
I have two was taking,
downloaded it.
And then when I went to send people to it,
I found out on the show on the podcast that it had been taken down and I was
like,
you gotta be fucking version is down,
but you can still get it other places.
But for them to apologize is meet saying,
okay,
you're weak.
You're allowed to take that down.
Right.
But for someone else to come in and say,
you can't make podcasts anymore,
right.
Is like really dangerous.
And that could have happened from that.
If someone had said,
no,
we're not going to take it down.
So radio lab is now hate monger.
Exactly.
Their support.
They support four Chan for Chan's about Hitler radio lab supports Hitler.
Yeah,
I mean this is,
this is a circular logic.
Yeah.
So the only answer is you have to have a strong line and it's causing direct
physical damage to someone that's everything's allowed.
Well,
W Dave,
they were,
the Internet is a horrible place.
It's a great place to though.
They should have never fucking taken that down.
Nope.
They should have been like that podcast.
You listen to it and it made me laugh so hard.
They told him how they got together in a trolling Isaac [inaudible],
science logic.
These things.
These are smart fucking people that figured out where that flag was
hilarious.
It was such a good podcast.
But being wild,
by the way,
meet talking about it on,
on people.
Like,
I can't believe you don't get it.
You know you,
you're fucking,
you always have all these white supremacists on.
Are you all right?
Are you this?
I mean,
every day people will tweet at me with stupid shit like that and that one
podcast me saying how great that podcast was in particular people saying what
the fuck is wrong with Joe Rogan?
You know,
I used to think he was a good guy.
Now I think he's a white supremacist or he's a fucking racist.
He's a KKK person.
Yeah,
I guess so.
Stupid.
One of my favorite books,
maybe my favorite,
I don't like to use that word favorite,
but like the fountainhead by Ayn rand and people go like,
oh social isyou know,
you know,
she took fucking social security in her old age.
She never did.
And I'm like,
okay,
okay.
And I used to shit on it and I'm right all the time myself.
And then I realize I've actually never read a book,
read the fountainhead and it changed my life like not even a little bit to the
direction of my career.
I still correct it freed me as an artist.
Oh,
so you've got to read it Bro.
But it's,
it's,
it's all about how to read a chapter of,
it took me a year and a half to read every chapter.
I'd sit down,
I think about it for two weeks.
What I read that the Jordan Peterson talks about her as a,
as a philosopher.
He doesn't like her as a novelist.
She's like,
she's great.
What,
what,
what was it about it?
Hey,
it
shows you a true artist and it shows you a,
a jobber and the jobber.
Yeah,
like pro wrestling style,
sort of someone who's just like doing it for the money as opposed to what a
pure,
like Abby,
Abby Martin,
he Harris,
what's her name?
Which one?
The journalists.
Abby Martin Martin,
who was,
she's like,
oh,
I don't want to just take money for reporting.
I want to actually real report now.
Yes.
So she's a ton of a true artist,
at least in that moment.
And none of us can be a fully true artist and none of us are really just full
jobbers.
We will have a little bit of artistic taste.
Even the jobbers have the fucking little bit of like,
I wanna do some interesting,
you know,
and the full artists,
it's just,
it's an almost an impossible,
a hundred percent ideal.
But if you can only aim for that,
if a sponsor says,
we need you to fucking tone it down to realize like,
oh fuck,
I just came up another four grand.
No,
sorry,
I can't use you anymore,
goddammit.
I hate this.
That's what fuck you money is all about sort of.
Yeah,
but this guy didn't have fuck you money in the,
this guy's like,
I'll go back up.
Mike's,
I'll go back to open mikes.
You can't take away my ability to freely do this no matter what.
So it freed me in terms of like being able to think that way,
who's really,
really informative to me.
But if I had just heard these people going,
fuck her,
she's a socialist.
And then you read it like,
Oh,
I'm not getting what you're saying.
I did this,
I,
I'm missing this amazing stuff.
So the people who will just say,
Oh fuck you,
four Chan is hatemongers.
It's like you didn't really even,
you're not even listening to what they're actually doing.
As soon as you eliminate nuance and you eat,
you have reductionist ideology,
right?
You just want to reduce something to,
oh,
he's racist.
Oh,
he's hateful.
he's this.
He's that,
that,
that is the,
that's where ideas go to die.
Does you,
you,
you eliminate what is what it is to be a human,
what needs to be a human is to be constantly conflicted,
to deal with a bunch of different contrary ideas,
bouncing around your head left and right all the time.
You know,
and if you,
if you want to eliminate the ability to talk to people that you don't agree
with,
boy,
you're living in a fucking bizarre bubble because you're not going to agree with
yourself five years from now.
Most likely.
Yeah.
I mean,
if I had an argument today,
15 years ago,
I'd be like,
man,
you're a fucking dumb ass.
You need to stop thinking this way.
You need to stop doing this.
He need to look at yourself more objectively.
Tell you why.
Think that.
And just like,
listen,
if,
I mean the fact that we're so divisive,
but like no one listens.
The other side I'll,
I'll give the easiest argument to me is abortion.
Where it's like,
well,
both sides of pro life,
the idea of life and both sides are also pro choice.
No one's against choice,
but you're not hearing the other side.
So one side is saying,
um,
it's a woman's right to choose her body.
It's her choice.
And it's like,
okay,
but yes,
it's her body,
but it ain't a tattoo.
There's,
you know,
there's more to it than just her body.
And then the other side,
it's like,
it's a human life.
Like,
okay,
yes,
it's a life,
but also this chick has to carry it for nine months.
She's gotta change her whole body in order to carry.
It's not just simply,
it's a life.
It's not like they're going in and murdering babies.
It's in a cuma.
So
can you guys actually talk,
can you guys really talk and own up to like,
it's no more than just one side ground.
Yeah.
Right.
The people with the pro choice or saying no,
it's a woman's right to choose and the people that are pro life,
so you know you're killing a baby and if you give up any ground,
the baby's going to die.
Or I'm going to take away a woman's right to have an abortion and then she's
going to have to carry a bunch of kids from people that raped her.
And there's,
this is the worst case scenario and extremes on both ends.
As a booker,
as a former booker,
someone who books a show,
they're like,
you need more women.
It's like,
oh,
I'm looking at hard,
but you have to understand that I'm not going to hurt my product over.
I do want diversity.
I want diversity of opinion on there.
I want diversity of experience.
I want some Australians,
I want some fucking black people.
Ali Said deek cause a far different life experience than I do.
Right.
You know,
forget about my race.
Just his life experience is way different.
You know,
all I see Deacon Byron Bowers,
both black guys gives a far different worldview.
Yeah.
So I do want that diversity of experience,
but I'm not going to hurt my PR.
I'm not gonna get some shitty guy who just was in prison,
doesn't have to tell the story.
Right?
So I'll work hard,
but meet me halfway.
I will do it,
but find me quality people.
So I'll go to fucking Atlanta and five ms pat.
But I'll go,
I have to go far for it.
So if somebody cancels on my show and now I have five white guys,
don't be like fuck you.
Look into a little more like I just had two chicks cancel,
so meet me halfway.
Well whenever you're looking for diversity as opposed to looking for the best
possible product,
you've got an issue.
And part of that best part is some diversity of opinion.
That is,
that is.
But,
but it should be good.
And there's no reason why the two are mutually exclusive.
Like the idea that there's only a certain limited amount of good ideas that come
mostly from white people is ridiculous.
Right?
So there's plenty of ideas that will come from Asians and plenty of ideas that
come from all sorts of different ethnicities that are also excellent.
So it's just finding them.
But when you guarantee that you're going to have five of this and five of that,
that's when you're going to have a real fucking thing.
So I had my friends,
my friend,
um,
Colette said that we're doing in the,
in the,
uh,
in the business world is they're taking what their industry is,
the number of let's say,
men and women only,
I forget I'm black and white and Latino,
whatever.
Just men and women,
they're taking the number of people in the industry and in order to correct,
uh,
an over use of males,
let's say,
or the other way over use of females and like autistic training,
you know,
but let's just say in the business world,
it's 70,
30,
making that up.
Okay.
Um,
so what you do is they force you instead of his faith where California is like,
you must put a woman on your board.
Yes.
Which means like,
okay,
if we just,
we had three board members,
one left and we have to hire a woman now wait,
Bill Gates just became available.
He wants to work on our board,
can't hire him,
can't hire him.
That's hurting my company.
You got to hire a cigarette time.
He's great.
Yeah,
so what they said is in order to correct it,
they will interview at a 10% higher rate than the industry numbers so that
there'll be exposed slightly to more of the people
that are underrepresented and over time that would correct the issue without
hurting any company.
I have to here,
well let me hear why you think you're right for the job and eventually you will
hear is people are like,
wow,
she was actually really good.
Let's actually heart here or there,
but if it's still bill gates,
you probably didn't get the job over him.
He's got his fucking,
he's got his resume.
Well that's where Jordan Peterson comes in with this equality of outcome id
argument and the equality of outcome argument is,
it's a dangerous argument if you guarantee a quality of outcome.
But I want to hear it that women are going to make exactly the same amount as
men.
And so even if the man works harder,
the women is still gonna make the same amount of money.
Well that's ridiculous.
Yeah.
Then vice versa cut up.
Sure.
But with the NFL,
the NFL said you have to interview,
I mean we're predominantly black.
You have to interview,
interview,
not hire,
interview one black candidate before you hire somebody.
So at least these people get heard and sometimes you go like,
that guy was actually pretty fucking good.
Let's really consider them.
And then they get hired a little more until it just shifts the needle.
Well,
I only qualified people.
Ideally what you would want is no racism,
no racism,
no sexism.
That's a deal.
And not to have to make some laws for it.
Yeah,
but we're not in that world where we live,
but it would be nice.
Yeah,
that would be what we really would really want is this is never an issue at all.
You're only getting people that are great at it and that way we,
if,
if racism was not an issue at all,
if there was no racism whatsoever,
what you would say is,
oh look,
it seems like Asian people gravitate towards this.
It seems like people have this color or this culture rather gravitate towards
this activity and I wonder why that is.
And a set of saying,
why don't you hire more white people?
You'd say,
it seems like white people aren't really interested in that job at the cleaners.
The cleaners in New York is the variation job.
Yes.
Well,
you're not like you need to hire white people.
You need to hire black people.
It's like it's a job.
That's why nobody cares.
Nobody cares.
But if it was a CEO of large financial institutions,
you would say,
this is ridiculous that it's all this and not that.
Ideally it would be a fascinating social experiment or a,
a social observation to find out what genders,
what sexual orientation,
what race,
what g w what ethnicities gravitate toward specific jobs.
If those jobs didn't have a hierarchy of desire,
right.
If,
if there wasn't some jobs that are far more desirable.
Yeah.
I mean,
one of the arguments I had really early on in Hollywood was with this guy who
was a really nice guy,
but he was Asian and he was saying,
there's no fucking rolls for Asian actors.
This is bullshit.
And I was like,
okay,
why don't you make roles?
It's like,
it's not that easy.
I go,
I get it.
I understand that it's not that easy,
but do you think that someone should have to write an Asian leading man because
you have a hard time getting a job,
right?
Like what should they do?
Like how should it show ugly people?
Right.
It's true.
Like what about,
what about people who are dwarves?
There's no,
there's very few jobs for that and the one guy's killing it.
That one guys dominated that game of Thrones.
Dude,
what'd you do?
Like what?
What?
What would you do to correct that is the question.
It's not whether or not the world is fair.
The world's not fair.
There's no five foot tall white guys that are playing in the NBA.
That's not fair either.
Yeah.
This weird shit that just happens to be reality.
Like what do you do to correct that?
And you know,
he was really adamant that Hollywood is racist and they're not,
not hiring Asians to be leading men and Asians.
And I'm like,
okay,
I see how it would be frustrating for you as an actor.
But if you've,
if you're a screenwriter and you're a guy who writes a story about a white guy
and moves into a haunted house and you know,
he falls in love with this woman and they buy a house together and the house
winds up being haunted and his monsters,
you're saying,
should you,
should someone have to change that to an Asian guy so that you get a job?
Yeah.
Well also simplistic because it's like not hearing the other,
the other argument,
it's like,
okay,
sure that Becca could be anybody that could,
it could be any,
any race,
right?
But if me,
I'm not Hollywood,
I'm all guy making this one movie,
right?
And if I cast an Asian,
I'm probably going to make far less money than if I cast a guy who looks like
most of the movie ticket purchasers,
which was a white guy or a famous person,
which you know is going to sell it Brad Pitt.
Sure,
absolutely.
So then it's like you want me to correct what Hollywood is,
but I'm not Hollywood.
I'm just this producer for this movie
that becomes,
that's something that my friend Frankie Renzulli said to me once,
he said,
there's no Hollywood.
Right.
That's what I said about the AIDS cure care.
Yeah.
Doctors have the cure,
but they make more,
they make more money in selling the treatment off the treatment.
But I'm like,
but there's no such thing as doctors.
There's doctors group.
So if one doctor had it,
he would be a billionaire if he just released the cure.
Well,
this is the main problem with conspiracy theory is that everyone's working
together.
Everyone's working together as a part of some grand thing to keep the knowledge
that the world's flat away from the general public,
like that kind of stupidity.
But that comes from a lack of understanding of how human beings interact with
each other and about how a magnificent a discovery so gigantic would be to the
one person that exposed it,
but that person is going to keep their mouth shut for what fucking reason.
What reason?
That's nonsense.
I will say with that in mind,
there is a thing that when you interview a white lady or a black dude for a job,
a lot of times your predispositions towards those races or genders go in and go
like,
I don't respect you as much as your mind is there.
I kind of like disrespect you a little.
I don't think you have the brain that someone who looks different has so now
you're like not letting them get the part or get the job.
They would have gotten not the part that Holly was so garbage part doesn't work
but the job because like ah,
really you're smart.
No.
Right.
A woman's
going to do the best job,
get the fuck out.
Whenever you see like a an actor who goes on to like write and direct his own
thing and like what?
Because most actors are fucking idiots.
Right.
And when you see when it's actually intelligent,
like I would not have expected that from you.
And that happens also with race and gender,
so that you do want to correct.
Yes.
Well that's what Billy Bob Thornton did with Slingblade.
He couldn't get jobs made his own.
So he decided,
you know what have this crazy character swingers.
Exactly.
Jon Favreau,
they decided to make his own movie.
Rocky.
Yeah.
I mean sort of.
Well,
he just made sure he played and he wrote it and he wrote it.
Yeah,
but you did go to a major studio,
but you,
you can't mandate creativity.
Creativity is a different element because like,
look how many fucking books is Stephen King written about Maine.
Like every other book,
it's about Maine.
You can't tell him he can't write a book about Maine because people from
Kenosha,
Wisconsin are upset and they think that you're,
you know,
your location.
But I do like what they're doing in the UK and they're like the first year of
Black Mirror,
which was UK based.
They don't,
they just let black guys play roles.
It's not,
they're not playing black person.
They're just like,
there's mixed race couples.
They're just,
they're just people.
They're way further along than we are in terms of that.
And so as a social consciousness of the design guys in general,
they don't see race as the European English,
English,
you know,
they say they see,
they see the ends and Pakistanis and stuff like that.
They see that race really hard still.
We actually probably see that less.
But in terms of black and white,
they're there,
which is way more like,
oh there's people.
Um,
that's interesting cause they don't have a history of slavery like we did
earlier.
I'm not sure.
I mean way back they had the more [inaudible] Shakespeare but like I dunno,
it's just not as bad as us.
Right.
For whatever reason,
I'm not really sure the causes.
But then people,
black guys can just play a role.
You understand an argument about that with,
with Black Mirror that I found was kind of silly.
Someone was saying,
Oh,
I'm upset about black mirror because it's like every show has a woman lead in
every show.
I go step away and look at the shows,
they're fucking fantastic.
Is that good?
Yeah.
Why do you,
but that's someone who was so upset by this whole idea of diversity and in
forced diversity that they're looking for it even when it's not relevant because
th the actual work itself,
it's so good.
She's like you shouldn't say the new Ghostbusters suck cause it was all women.
Right.
You said the new Ghostbusters suck because no one was calling for a remake of it
and it sucked.
Or Star Wars,
the new star wars.
Like when you had uh,
Carrie Fisher and Laura dern were like the major generals and you're like what?
This doesn't even work.
Like maybe it doesn't work because it wasn't written well and because they
didn't really pull it off.
But you're telling me you couldn't have some bad ass chick like Sigourney weaver
when she was in aliens who dominated the film and nobody gave a fuck that she
was the lead and we look up cause it was so good.
He was so good.
The blonde chick is from game of Thrones.
Perfect.
Cause you know and Searcy's yes,
there are no one's like,
oh yeah,
whatever.
It's like no one thinks of them is women.
They're just like strong characters.
Omar from the wire who was gay and black,
like no one cares because it was just like he nailed it.
But then how do you,
did you have to like,
like not see it and black who's going to be great in this and also give a
representation of,
you can't make all the gangsters white because it'd be unrealistic.
You know what I mean?
We've seen this in comedy too,
right?
We've seen there's a difference between in forced diversity and people who just
happen to be diverse,
but our brilliant,
true,
and we've seen this where they're trying to enforce like certain aspects of
standard mustaches.
You're going to make your product worse.
Yeah.
Well we,
I mean,
how many times have we seen this?
And people will say,
Hey,
you know,
why aren't there more women at the comedy store and why aren't there more this?
Why aren't there more that?
Whoops.
Oh yeah.
That lady who said like,
where'd he come?
He's only got three spots last month.
Explained that.
But where what you're doing is accusing,
but if you're actually asking why would it come and go?
I got three spots last month is because what it comes called in for three spots
last month,
she gets every spot she wanted.
She will tell you that if you're asked to her face,
she's one of the ones who long you don't get,
you don't call in and not get a spot.
There are certain people that get the spots they want.
Yeah.
So she's one of them.
So the answer is she's busy.
She has.
Yeah,
exactly.
The answer isn't causing sexism there.
Well that's nonsense though that that kind of thinking.
He almost always comes from people who suck.
If you look at their art,
they're almost always bad.
That's just a fact.
They want Liza about this recently.
It's not new.
It made me realize same thing when Dan Cook up,
big people are like,
oh cause he's good looking.
And that was a bunch of sucky guys who weren't killing every set like Dane was.
Sure.
And they'll go on,
there must be a reason other than it's on me.
Why I'm not as big as him.
So how about the good looking thing that's off me?
I have no control over that.
And it's really like,
dude,
that Guy Kills 19 Times at a 20 and you kill two out of 20 yeah.
Like can you possibly say it could be based on that,
but it's the people that are complaining are almost never doing well anyway.
So this is why they complaining.
I mean,
what,
what's,
what's going,
I mean you're not going to hear certain people.
You're going to hear a bill burr complaining about other people don't.
Chappelle said it,
it goes,
I mean,
black comics who do well,
they're all successful hugely.
You guys.
If you're doing well on stage consistently as a black comic,
there's no question you'll be,
you'll be doing,
you'll be making doctor money.
He didn't say that,
but like that's what it is.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
Well comedy in many ways is very egalitarian in that way.
Last year.
Yeah.
I mean,
you are what you are,
you know,
either you're really funny or you're not.
And those black rooms of black comics,
it was something it's like,
so like I'm in that doesn't relate to certain white audiences.
Like I just can't figure it up.
But there's rooms for them.
There's a lot of the Mexican rooms where they do half their pumps lines in
Spanish.
That wouldn't play the comedy store,
but it would play in certain audiences as used to do Miami.
He would do Spanglish.
He would have his punchlines to be in Spanish and people would follow the
fucking chair laughing.
And if you were a white guy who didn't swear,
good luck.
Good luck.
Jump out a window.
That was another thing.
Oh,
you're dirty.
That's why he's successful.
That's a big thing,
man.
Just start crushing and it's won't be an issue.
Yeah.
Well that was a nonsense issue to like,
I don't want to fall someone dirty.
Yeah.
Why not?
Why?
What difference does it have?
But this idea that like,
I'm not getting a hook as a reason.
It's not new.
This has been going on as a reason to be like off me,
why I'm not doing well.
Yeah,
and it does.
I think the real sexism,
especially for women is having to work with a bunch of people that are trying to
fuck you all the time.
Especially I think at open mics when you're already ready to quit anyway.
Yeah,
you're about ready to quit.
And now this fucking,
these creeps around and there's no one to talk to.
What the fucking call the coffee shop on the homeless.
I mean for real homeless people line up for open mics.
There's a giant percentage of them that are out of their fucking mind.
So if you're some girl who already feels vulnerable around men to begin with
because you're smaller and you know you're a target for sexual harassment
manager to go talk to them like,
Hey,
this guy's fucking,
can you walk me to my car?
No rules.
You know,
sign up.
There's 30 other people sign up.
You wait around for your name to be called.
If you're lucky,
you get three minutes and you're still no matter what,
five years away from making a dollar.
So it's like,
you know what,
fuck it,
I'm done.
If Mary Lynn Rice Cup today gets harassed,
she's not going to quit.
It's still making money.
Right.
You know,
she'll,
she might not come to the store anymore if nobody does anything about it.
Um,
but people would do,
so there's a place to go to for like,
hey you need to get rid of this guy and this audience member can't come anymore.
And that's just comedy.
I mean with any job issue.
Well also with men,
men are fucking stupid.
Okay.
If you're working with a man and a,
you're nice that man,
he assumes you want to fuck him cause this how this is evolution worked.
Yeah,
we're monkeys just my arm and it's like,
oh for the next two days,
if a woman is like kind to a guy and get some coffee,
the guy thinks she wants to suck his dick cause he's stupid because this is how
we're programmed.
We're programmed to think that women who are nice to us,
if that woman is attractive,
she must be sending a signal.
She wants sexual attention.
It can't just be some completely platonic workplace situation.
That's not possible because eight hours a day when you're working with someone,
you develop feelings and thoughts and ideas about that person.
I realized that we're not,
we're doing the nastiest show,
the Montreal and a,
there's all these young interns,
some of them women and young people are cuter than old people.
I don't know to tell you,
I'll stand by all your wants to fucking talk to every magazine
and you get this idea and you're there a week early from everybody else in
Nancy.
She'll start to weight earlier,
so you're pretty much the only English speaking show while the French stuff is
going on and these interns come out and you're like,
Ooh,
I think I can fuck one of them.
And then it hit me like,
oh wait,
there's also male interns who also showing up to the shows and you're like,
oh,
they're all just
comedy fans and I'm reading in these wind maci flirting.
Whereas they're coming when they're exhibiting the literally the exact same
behavior as the men who are coming,
coming to like,
I want to hang out with the comedian and they might want hook,
they might not,
but I'm putting something on them only because of their gender and then it's
like,
okay,
step back.
You can't fuck any of these people.
Yeah.
That's must be what it's like if you're the manager of an office and there's a
cute woman who works for you and a guy who's fat and gross and they're both
exhibiting the exact same friendly behavior towards you.
You don't assume the fact,
I want to suck your Dick.
Right.
And then,
and then also it's like if you can still hook up,
but they have to do all the work.
The underling has to do all the pushing you,
even though I don't think you can in an office environment,
I think of the underling keeps pushing there.
They have good push,
hard to push on.
You can,
you can be like,
what are you doing this weekend?
And every body I was like,
I'm going to move.
You want to come like,
oh sure.
Anybody else want to cut?
Like you have to like really not push and put them in a position.
Mm.
Yeah.
And there's people going to take advantage of that on both sides.
And even on the female side,
um,
there's a friend of mine who works at vice and uh,
he was talking to me about this woman who was making these like really obvious,
um,
advances.
She was trying to have sex with him and uh,
he contacted one of the other guys that he works with that is also there and
he's like,
do not fuck her.
Like she is upwardly mobile.
Like what she was doing,
she tried to fuck her way up to the top.
She did it to this guy and then she called sexual harassment on him after she
flirted with him and he's got some fucking,
some advance that she shouldn't have and some,
some nonsense when people are political.
Some people are very calculated and some people are sociopaths and they exist
with vaginas.
They exist with penises.
It's just this is part of being a person.
There's some people that are just bad people,
but there's also some women who were like power and that's not wrong.
Oh,
you're a manager.
Right.
It's justifiably,
makes me want to fuck you a little more.
And so that's okay too.
Yeah.
And well there's some women also that like being in power and we hate those
women,
but we don't hate the men who like to be empowered.
That's a weird thing to like a woman wants to run shit.
We're like,
look at this crazy bitch wanting to run everything.
Whereas a guy who wants to run shit seems totally normal.
I will say it's a bigger wrong,
it's like what are you most likely want to avoid?
You know,
and it seems like a bigger wrong for someone to have to like worry about getting
fucking,
not just being able to do their job versus Oh,
this chick wants to sleep with me because she wants to get ahead.
Yeah.
Well that's easy to avoid is for the guidance.
There's no physical threat,
eh,
there's never a physical threat from that guy.
Feel like,
well I got my ass grabs like,
and you could end it anytime he wants to not come on.
Stop it.
I mean in last year to like really a mess and you know,
you've just vulnerable psychologically,
physically all the time.
Bubs,
you're an aberration or an operation.
Yeah.
I don't know how to correct it.
We're lucky we don't have to work with people all day man.
Beat people in a fucking office environment.
They're working around people all day and people have some weird shit.
And then you go to the company Christmas party and some guy who works with your
wife's had some creepy shit to you cause you know he's been like,
he's been coveting your wife behind your back and you know he wants her and you
know he's,
he talks shit about you to her and she tells you and that kind of shit is so
normal man.
Because you think about how many hours are in a day,
you have 24 hours in a day.
Eight of them you're sleeping.
Okay.
So how much time is commuting?
How much time is work?
Most of your day is at work,
so your life is not what your spouse,
you might not hook up with them,
but you were interacting with them and then the disproportionate way,
yeah.
Do you think with people sometimes talk about me to going too far,
but let's talk about for a second like me to going the right level.
Do you think,
and we don't work in an office job,
so we're just guessing,
right?
You think sexual harassments or down now and last year,
men who are creeps are probably a little more cautious.
I remember after them and see a video,
people all over open Mikes,
we're calling each other out on it.
Yeah.
And then occasionally it was a question of it went too far.
We were like,
you stole that joke from,
it's like,
do we both talked about the same movie and you're trying to write me off my
whole career off because I talked about,
uh,
you know,
whatever gets with wolves and so are you.
But your thing was about the native Americans do,
your thing was about the fucking co,
you know,
the dog they had.
And so I'm sure it went too far here or there,
but it was nice where it like it was no longer acceptable to steal jokes.
Yes.
And it wasn't just something we're going to tolerate.
Right.
It's gotta be like that too.
With this meat to stuff.
It's no longer acceptable that fucking patent ass.
Exactly.
When you can be like wood or I just wanted to an everyone else.
Even the guys like,
dude,
no dude,
I couldn't imagine being a man where rather than reality,
I couldn't imagine being a woman working for a man who wanted to fuck me and me
getting a raise,
me getting some sort of a upward movement in my career is dependent upon this
person making a decision and this person is always trying to fuck me.
That'd be disgusting.
And that's what a lot of women have to deal with all day long and that's only
one step of it.
How about the fucking Bill Cosby step?
How about you can't leave your fucking drink alone.
You can't leave your drink.
That's a reality with a lot of women.
That's not a reality with you or me.
When I was trying to rape us.
Fuck.
I mean there's a lot of shit that women have to think about that we don't have
to think about a lot.
Many,
many,
many things.
Yeah,
it is interesting.
This now is all coming up here.
Like what?
How many of you had some damn fuck.
It's worse than I thought.
A lot of it's too cause like you just want to believe the best in the world and
people and so when you're like this you're like,
no,
that can't happen that much.
It's not like you're problem,
you're not doing it,
but you just don't want to believe that's so removed.
Probably some kid can get chopped up by some,
you know,
some monster,
right?
Like no,
Yeah,
we're moving.
We don't see it as much.
It's not directed us.
So they've been fucked up worlds,
man.
Our world is,
everybody smokes pot.
Almost everybody drinks,
you know,
everybody's a deviant.
Everybody is impossible for them to have a regular job.
Every single one of us that successful as a comic,
it's virtually impossible for any of us to have ever existed.
In an office environment and survived.
Yeah,
we're too fucked up,
but we're perfect for comedy.
You know what I mean?
So like us,
US talking about office politics and office environments,
so we a fucking big deal.
It's really what it is.
Fools.
That's why I think it's funny when people say like talk about,
I don't know,
Louie or something where it's like,
it was a comedy festival,
so it was,
it was at their job and it's like,
oh no,
no,
no.
You just don't understand what comedy is.
Safety issue.
If it was a workplace then,
then,
then you would have to say like,
by the way,
actually do people do coke at the workplace?
We're now job people actually consensually fuck doing work at our workplace.
Like is that happens to a lot of pot smoking at our workplace?
Yeah.
Like it's not,
it's not,
it's not.
Workplace has a designated pot-smoking place and now where we are,
you're in the green room,
you can't fuck with anybody,
but you can,
you can't smoke.
Yeah.
It's not,
it's not a workplace.
well,
you should still have the rights to safety.
But it ain't a workplace.
Well,
and you should,
it's all WWE.
Like here's the thing,
like say if you're Tom and Christina,
yeah.
You're married together.
Yeah.
You could fuck in the green room.
Lock the door and who's going to stop you so you could fuck at the workplace.
Yeah.
Yeah,
you could.
That's not an issue.
You people fucking agreement all the time.
Like they'd beat it.
This girl is coming in,
but you can't fuck if you know you're the manager and she's a secretary and you
pull her into your office,
you get fired for that.
Even if it's your wife,
you're not allowed to do that.
A real work.
You can't fuck fuck at work.
When we're Constanza got fired,
he goes,
is that not alone?
What did he do at work?
And then they were like,
we caught you on camera goes,
oh,
what I did,
was that a problem?
I didn't realize trying to lie his way out of it.
Yeah.
Well,
I think people listen to more and it's slow.
And I think at the,
the,
the conversation gets sidetracked when you,
you,
you hit on punishment too much.
When people hit on punishment,
like this person needs to go away.
It's like,
can we get back to the fucking,
same thing with Michael Vick.
It's when you're talking about whether he should put that away.
Football,
it's like,
now you've sidetrack me from just saying,
don't kill dogs.
I'm on your side.
But like,
oh,
now you've sidetrack me to go.
No,
no.
He should be allowed to like football.
That has nothing to do with it.
Let's just get back always to the argument like let's make it safer for chicks
in the workplace.
Let's not let a black guy and not get hired when he's deserving.
You know,
let's fix that stuff.
The punishment side tracks as you can still talk about it,
but not when you're emotional.
I think one thing that we've come within this conversation as a job suck jobs
do,
so no one should have them because if you have them,
people want to fuck you that you work with.
Yeah.
I think the,
that's the solution when it's like men need to shut up.
It's like,
all right,
well then we can't help you or hurt you if in your shout out.
Those people are just,
there's French,
there's loud fringe people.
Like you know,
that's just one,
one of my favorite tweets that I saved from this feminist woman that said,
all white males are trash unless proven otherwise.
It's like,
okay,
well we're not going to have them,
but you want our help,
so,
okay,
good luck with that unless proven otherwise.
That's a ridiculous way to look at things.
What if a man said that all women are constantly,
it's proven otherwise that's a bad person.
Well,
it's also like the answer to,
I dunno,
White Dude,
he's been in charge forever,
is not fuck these people over who I wasn't here for forever.
Right.
People just need to stop talking.
Yeah.
And it's like,
okay,
okay.
That's the answer is lack of racism,
lack of sex,
complete lack.
Even in judging white people,
even in judging white males,
even in judging white males in a position of power like this should be no
racism.
There should be no discrimination and people should be presidential candidate
early,
early last time.
And they're like,
how do you feel that black lives matter?
And he hadn't heard about it yet.
And he goes,
what?
And he was super progressive.
It's like,
of course black lives matter.
All lives matter.
We tie.
Yeah.
And like you can't see the logo for that.
That's a slogan for the other side.
And they were like,
wrote him off and he's like,
yeah,
no,
a bunch of fucking three words.
Summation of the whole argument.
Yeah.
Black lives matter or all lives matter.
And Bernie Sanders said,
black lives matter.
And he said,
why?
And people like,
Oh,
you're stupid progressive.
We love you,
Bernie.
You're playing by the rules that we've established and you saying the things
that we make,
you say,
yeah,
well of course all lives matter.
But black lives matter as well.
So the yellow lives matter also.
It's too,
it's too crazy too.
It didn't work as a slogan.
If you go,
hey,
we need to figure out why black people are getting shot at a higher rate and
their percentages,
um,
then white people by cops.
So we need to like curb that immediately.
And we didn't make it somewhere where you can actually trust the police to
represent you all and not have a fear of them.
It's like,
that's not a slogan you can throw out.
Right.
But if you said that,
then nobody's gonna like,
no,
you should have to worry about cups.
It's like we were just like,
get behind that super deep and complex conversation about systemic racism in
communities where like in Baltimore,
where they literally established zones where black people couldn't buy homes.
And now you're gonna sum up the three words.
You've got giant cultural issues that should be addressed on literally a
nationwide scale.
Like we're,
we're interested in building nations and helping people in Afghanistan and the
giving aid to Saudi Arabia and all these different,
uh,
fill in the blank with whatever country it is.
How the fuck are they not fixing the south side of Chicago?
Yeah.
I mean,
how the fuck are they not fixing Baltimore?
How do they not going to Compton,
Flint water,
still many drinkable,
goddammit.
Elon Musk has to step in and say he's going to fix your water.
By the way,
you and I,
we have no idea about the backstory to it and how to fix it.
We ever know pennies in our opinions are worthless.
They're just worthless.
No solutions,
neither.
Neither one us have any
skin in the game.
We're talking out of our ass,
but,
but we're going to do anything really wrong to people without hurting anybody.
But if we look want to look at things objectively,
that is a real valid
argument.
Real valid point of discussion.
It's like,
sure,
black lives matter,
but you know what else matters really bad.
Communities that have been bad for decade after decade after decade and they're
not being addressed by any politicians.
They're not being addressed by any community leaders.
No one is stepping in and saying,
hey,
before we do anything involving any other country,
we've got to fix all the problems we have right here.
And they can be fixed.
They can be fixed.
And it might take decades.
It might take years.
I don't know how long it's going to take,
but it's not going to be fixed at all if we do nothing.
If we,
we've we've,
that's also part of this argument that goes too far.
The pendulum was here.
We want it back in the middle.
It's just going to have to swing a little too far and then come back when we're
talking about me too and and sexual harassment and rape and all this stuff.
I think one of the things that we're dealing with is information.
Does distribution of information is occurring at a rate that's unprecedented.
It's never been like this before and I think there's a real step that's going to
happen with human beings where you're not,
you're going to be able to literally read minds and this is going to happen
through some sort of a merging with humans and technology.
Elon Musk believes it's going to be this thing that he's,
he's releasing something in the next few months called neuro link and this neuro
link is going to somehow or another increase the bandwidth between people and
information.
At a rate that's going to literally change what a human being is.
And the way he was explaining it was very vague.
But you know,
when you're talking about a guy like Elon Musk and the insane ideas that he has
bounced around inside it's fucking robot brain.
I believe him,
and I believe this is one step,
just like no one could have ever predicted the Internet in 1960 no one ever
would have thought other than I think Malcolm Mcluhan,
uh,
had some people had some,
yeah,
some people that,
some ideas of,
of what,
what could possibly happen.
But
no one,
no average person saw this comment.
And I think no average person is going to see these next stages of integration
between human beings and technology.
And one of them is going to be some sort of a translation device,
some sort of a translation device that translates not just languages but
thoughts and a universal language that is,
it's,
it defies economic boundaries,
political boundaries,
geographic boundaries,
something that everyone's going to be able to understand.
Like the real problem,
like Tower of Babel argument is that,
you know,
if someone's talking in Bangladesh and someone's talking in Japan,
it's someone's talking in America,
there's so many different ways of saying things.
It's too hard to understand the mall.
No one knows all the languages,
right.
Very QP nuance.
Somebody translated the stranger.
Yeah.
Four sentences.
Um,
and it's a French I think,
but it's,
it's mother died yesterday or was it the day before?
I can't be sure.
And they have to have arguments about she used mother,
she's mom should use Mama.
Like,
which one is the actually meaning in French and not just get like a sterile one,
but like a,
uh,
a normalized once.
I can't,
it's like,
it's,
it's beyond just translation.
So,
yeah.
So go ahead.
And I think this is one of the giant problems with whenever you're dealing with
nationalism,
whenever you're dealing with this idea of the other,
that someone from another place is different than you kids.
And Yemen's lives don't matter nearly as much as,
um,
I dunno,
someone not getting hired for late night TV is a perfect example because they're
using drones to launch missiles into a country that we're not even supposed to
be at war with.
Okay.
They're going after it's not insurgence.
Yeah.
A six year old little girl is dead times a thousand.
Right.
But if one died because like,
but it's nice that,
okay,
it's not happening in Chicago or San Francisco,
right.
We're just not drones launching into the East village.
So because that's not happening,
we don't think of it as a concern of ours and this,
I think these hurdles,
these are informational hurdles as much as their geographical hurdles and their
language hurdles.
And these are,
these are hurdles of understanding.
And I think as our realm of understanding expands and we get a better
understanding of the idea that we really are just human beings in different
places and that you are no different than me.
And I'm no different from some kid who lives in China and that we're all just
human beings.
And the what of our differences are they pale in comparison to our similarities
and also the random chance that you were born in Maryland and I was born in New
Jersey.
This randomness and this idea that you take pride in that is so foolhardy and so
ridiculous.
And the idea that somehow or another we're on some sort of a tribe and this is
something that human beings will cling to for security and safety.
And we go with tribe,
left and tribe,
right?
And we go with tribe progressive and tried conservative and we go with tribe,
American tribe,
Canada and tribe,
Mexico.
It's all foolishness.
And I think as technology expands,
that will be more and more preposterous.
And you're,
you're starting to see this with even the way people view religion.
If you look to people from just a few decades ago,
um,
how many people in this country thought they were,
uh,
how many identified as atheist?
It's quite a bit less than today.
Quite a bit more identify with today because you start to understand more about
religion.
There's Google people can um,
and Bill Maher and Sam Harris,
we're actually talking about this on a podcast recently.
Um,
cause they were talking about the 10th anniversary of Religious Bill Maher's
documentary.
They made a really good point
that Google came along and when Google came along,
people were allowed to then research the history of Mormonism where they never
really could before.
And they go,
wait,
he was 14 and 18,
20 and Joseph Smith was just a kid and he made up a bunch of find me a 14 year
old.
It's not full of shit.
That's way more impressive.
And then Scientology and,
and,
and many of the,
you know,
many of the chapters in the Bible,
when people look at the difference between the New Testament,
the old testament who wrote it and why and,
and how many passages were removed and edited by human beings.
How we,
you decide the work of God,
like what gets to be released and what's not.
The,
all that stuff is,
it's kindle now.
It's like,
man,
it's kindling for the fire of enlightenment and in that fire spreading.
And I think that it's an informational tool and these,
this fire enlightenment is,
is,
it's a bad term fire enlightenment.
But Fred,
when you realize too,
when it really does get out,
we're like,
Whoa,
I didn't realize,
right.
Got It done.
And we think about how many women you like,
they were talking about this a long time ago and you're like,
come on man,
relax honey.
Yeah,
exactly like that.
It's okay.
And now you're like,
fuck,
I guess it is really bad.
Well,
the Cosby,
the Cosby thing,
I remember hearing about that when I was at news radio.
Yeah.
It was always a thing.
Like,
I don't know,
maybe think about it like in terms of perse actress.
Yeah,
that was my sister who went through or my mom.
That's another reason too where I'll try to put myself in the place.
I'm pretty good at.
Like,
I mean you've seen me tell stories.
I got worked up,
you know,
I could put myself in a place I was or you know,
imagine something pretty,
pretty good.
And so it's like,
yeah,
if it was your sister,
your mom,
your girlfriend,
your wife,
daughter.
Going through it,
you'd be like,
I'll fucking kill that guy.
You know?
It's like,
you're so mad.
But then the same thing when I hear about like,
I dunno like Louie and if my sister is like told me that,
I'd be like,
well he did what he often funny
red pubes how many of them were gray?
Yeah,
like right.
Yeah.
I try to put in them as a position,
as best as I can.
I still don't have to go through it if it's wrong,
but like there's levels,
there's level.
But also it's like getting back to what it's like.
You really hear about little stuff now and you're like,
whoa.
But there's also,
in terms of someone like Louie,
there's gotta be a road to redemption.
And this is one of the problems with people that are so fucking angry is that
they don't think there's any road to redemption.
They want career to be taken away and never play again.
But the Michael Vick thing is different.
Cause Michael Vick tortured and murdered,
he didn't murder murder,
murder.
But he also went to jail at the time that the state said you would need to do
this for what he did,
he'd served his time.
He lost his freedom for four years.
Yes.
Yeah,
so his job that he had before has nothing to do with it,
but it does come down to people going,
I,
I'm not through with you suffering yet.
Okay.
Same thing with Louis.
Still think it's a different,
I'm not through with you suffered,
you represent killing about two women torturing versus different.
Do you represent evil to women?
Just cause he beat off.
He's a representative of that.
Of course you're just a creeper but like not even that I don't think but like
but like pervert I guess.
What are Ya?
I Dunno man.
Actually deviant hang out with two girls who were like talking dirty to you for
two days ago on drinks with them and you start getting like the idea,
it's like I think I got to hook up.
I think I might have a threesome.
And they're like that's not enough reason to go for,
it's like,
yeah,
you're right.
Like I need more signs for like,
well,
let me say you want to go out for drinks?
And I do.
It's like still,
no,
it's not enough of a sign.
It's like,
y'all,
you're right,
you're right.
Oh,
I know all about them.
Up to my hotel room.
That's usually pretty universal sign and they're coming there.
Came to my hotel room.
No,
that's not enough.
You're right.
All these signs is not enough to tell you what,
I'll just ask outright,
can I fucking jerk off in front of you?
And they said,
yes.
No,
that's still not enough.
What are you talking about?
Well,
here's the,
so no,
not creeper,
but he represents things to people.
Just like Roseanne represented Trump when she said she has a character of voted
for Trump and Nixon the show.
So because the representative evil gets women,
they go,
just get rid of that representative and they're not seeing them as a human being
that people actually know that is a human as a person.
Not only that,
if someone says yes,
if you ask,
can I beat off in front of you?
And they say yes and then never side.
No,
no,
I was just kidding.
Just kidding.
Does leave the yes out there.
We're done here.
We're done.
Did you say?
Yes.
So like if a girl says,
can I,
can I play with my pussy in front of you?
And you go,
yeah.
And then she does he go,
well that was fucking disgusting and I can't believe this happened.
And I'm going right to the press.
Like,
wait a minute.
Did you say yes?
Like,
okay,
here's one thing is if this is a,
an aggressive,
angry person,
a traps you to room,
you've,
you only way you can get out.
The only way you can get out of this room as you let this guy beat off in front
of you and you've,
you fearful of your life,
people don't really,
most people don't really care.
I saw him on stage of one cough like crazy.
They were so happy.
And when he goes,
cause I'm just going to do jokes tonight.
Everyone's like,
fuck yes.
Yeah,
just to jokes,
jokes.
We just want to see what we loved about two years ago,
10 months ago.
And Michael Vick,
we just want you to see you throw,
we're done with that.
You digital crime or we still hate you.
It has nothing to do with Michael Richards.
How you got your job?
He didn't,
he just,
he yelled out racist shit.
But like,
but like nobody,
nobody saw it.
Nobody liked him on stage.
But the thing,
yeah,
you're right.
So it's like I'm not missing anything.
Lily is,
you know,
you,
there's gotta be some path of redemption for everybody.
Yeah.
For everybody.
I mean human beings.
Very wild.
Bill Cosby.
No,
not go up at a prison talent show.
no,
no.
It's over.
He can't even go up in prison.
No.
Disagree.
No,
I'm kidding.
I took until you show me the connection to what he did versus this job.
You know what I mean?
If you Pete rose bed on baseball,
he hurt the job he was doing so that you got like,
you can't be in baseball anymore cause you fucked over baseball.
But did he fuck over baseball by betting on it?
Yeah.
He,
they show he liked probably through some games or he like use his relievers in
situations.
He wouldn't have that.
He can't use them tomorrow because you fucked over baseball that fuck.
So you basically shut its doors to you if you steal jokes.
Yes.
You maybe there is a path to redemption maybe,
but you fucked over jokes.
Well you fucked over other comments so you fucked over the experience.
You're talking about getting back into it.
But that guy can go to the supermarket.
Yes,
he can work at another job because that has nothing.
You haven't shown me a connection to another job.
See the thing about the jokes dealing thing,
and this is where it gets really,
really weird,
is there's no real punishment other than people deciding they don't like you
because you're a joke thief and that is the real punishment.
Like you're talking like a Twitter take you down.
It's like,
no,
no.
What I'm saying is it's different than someone who steals cars,
right?
Someone steals cars.
The punishment setup.
Yeah,
you go to jail.
It's illegal.
If someone steals jokes like you basically done the same thing,
you've stolen a thing and you know that thing is a,
the thing is,
yeah,
you also a little different because you can still do your jokes.
If I stay there,
a car,
you can't have her caught on the one on.
If somebody goes on in front of you like we know him and see it did and does
your headline.
Europe is closing bit on purpose,
on purpose to fuck with you.
He would do closing bits.
That was Freddie fucking with Bobby once and he was like,
Oh,
you're going to love it.
I mean he would fuck with Bobby populate,
but it wasn't.
Yeah,
it was to fuck with Bobby.
He said,
you've got to love this nice guy.
He's so funny and Bobby,
all the wanted was Freddy support.
He looked up to him so hard and he could never get it.
You're going to love this next guy.
Does this joke about selling corn on the side of the road and he's like,
y'all and Coney corn corner yells so good.
He has this other bit about,
about his Dallas bits.
He would just tell the,
the ending punchlines that this bit to pull his legs out from under him.
That's a terrible thing.
He was fucking with him,
but he wasn't doing to gain himself.
Only to hurt Bobby and only in one moment that I ever saw,
but it was like,
fuck you got me bad.
Yeah.
I mean they were bitter enemies.
It was like something about routing,
routing them out to somebody a long time before those arguments.
Waco,
it's done.
But like they hated each other back then.
Freddie hated Bobby.
Bobby.
They hated them back only because the thing about people getting caught,
it's like the punishments real though.
It's almost better than going to jail like we don't.
We know about you now.
Not only do we know about you now,
but the public knows about you now and the disdain is palpable.
It's real.
And you see it not just with him,
not just hope.
You can see it,
but here's a few of them.
And you can tell a difference too between somebody going back,
I took that guys joke versus that guy takes jokes.
Know what I mean?
The back.
I took
that guy that's out there and that's real.
Right.
But it doesn't quite stick as much as like we all just know that guy steals
jokes.
Right.
You know,
not a possible parallel.
It's like over and over again,
like such a clarity to in the difference between the jokes,
they come up with it on their own and the jokes that they steal.
You can keep going up.
You can still settle theaters.
So your punishment is,
we know about you.
I can't,
you can't saw theater style.
That's what happens to them eventually.
But a lot of them still do the name one.
Dan Cook continue to sell it theater as well.
He's does it.
So things dog died off eventually,
but a lot of people die off too.
But during while it was happening,
there was no real,
he was still doing massive numbers.
Meant CEO's still doing living better than most a level comics.
Even after all that,
you mean even right now actually he's still makes more money than,
than Mike [inaudible] does.
You know,
then really good comments in big j does,
you know,
he probably still makes more money than I do it to be honest.
You know what I'm doing.
It's greatest I've ever done,
but like so it's like it doesn't get taken away from you completely.
You'll never get the respect of your peers.
That's a big deal with us.
That's what we're talking about.
This in the back of the comedy store,
when he was talking about a bunch of shit,
he was calling through and splitting up and all this and that.
He goes,
listen,
at the end of the day,
all I give a fuck about,
do I have the love and respect of my peers?
Yeah.
And those guys don't have it and it fucking drives them crazy and kind of
punishment.
You can take jokes and do whatever,
but like
we're never going to look up to you and that's what you want.
Yeah.
And on that,
nobody hates Larry.
Nobody hates Larry.
They might,
they might think he's like lame,
but nobody hates him.
Larry the cable guy.
Yeah,
he's a great guy.
Great Guy.
I want one more story before I go about this.
Had really an MMA podcast.
It's kind of not,
but it is release it over.
He was always like that though.
I did this thing,
you helped me like organize a little bit or or arrange it in my head where I was
really stoked on the experience La people have with medical marijuana and I said
it's not fair that other people don't get to have this experience of taking
these breast trips at a UFC.
How great it is.
And I was like,
I'm going to have an event called hunt for the edible.
Oh No.
And I am going to hide marijuana,
have a scavenger hunt.
At first I thought like have some clues and they'll come to me.
I'll give it to them.
Like a cop will do that and come to you.
You're like the point.
Good point.
I gotta hide this.
So I would hide drugs.
I mean drugs but only marijuana.
A onetime mushrooms.
But like a,
at UFC I would have access to it beforehand.
When we went to the MGM,
if for the weigh ins,
half of it was shut down.
So the other half I could just walk through freely and I would hide.
I would tape these breaths trips to somewhere.
The first one's underneath the bathroom,
sink in a fucking in one of the bathrooms and draw clues on Twitter.
Released them every five minutes,
plan it out ahead of time.
But one was like,
if you want to get high,
go up a level.
And it's like,
okay.
People were like,
run up.
People got into it,
they run up levels and then they,
until this guy was like,
I think it's right here,
this bathroom sink.
Then he looked under it on did it,
had a note in there with the proper dosage,
you know,
I don't know.
I want to fuck anybody over.
And uh,
it became such a fun,
fun time.
I got to assume the powers that be knew about it and said nothing.
Is it plausible that I ability,
I don't know.
I don't care.
Did I promote it?
No.
I tell people and I don't think so.
Yeah.
So how did they,
how do you think they knew about it?
Twitter,
I might've mentioned it on the podcast or something,
but um,
it was so fun for me.
Um,
and I would do it over and over again and then I would go back.
I remember looking times where I would go,
I would tape it to like a,
a pillar somewhere.
I like the Pearl and I would go to see if it's found under his feet.
Usher go like as I was looking at,
he didn't know.
I was wondering who hit it,
you know,
he,
he would just go,
what's you're looking for is no longer here because I guess a bunch of people
kept coming to this pillar and they would follow the clues.
No one said it.
Someone once said it's found now cut the game later.
I would go in and delete all the clues.
I'm not looking to fuck over the cops or anything like that,
but it was so fun.
One time nobody found one.
I was always living like still here.
I'm fucking taken it off using it myself.
But it usually had high two of them underneath the fucking fire extinguisher,
something like that.
Now one time,
um,
somebody found it and then came down and sat like right behind me and Shandra
and then,
um,
these,
these usher slash security guards came and found the guy and said,
hey,
I need you to come with me.
And they took them out and I was like,
fuck.
He kept his mouth.
He wasn't like,
it was just getting in front of me.
And I sat there for about 30 seconds and I was like,
I got to go Shandra.
I gotta go fucking,
I got to turn myself in on this.
Oh yeah.
And she was like,
what am I,
I'm,
I'm I letting this fucking kid,
dude,
fuck.
I gotta say like,
no,
I hit it.
I'll figure it out.
And then I went up there and they were like,
oh no.
They were just moving our seats because we were sitting around,
suits were fine.
I was like,
oh,
that guy.
Thank God.
Didn't you get busted in like Minneapolis or some shit at the mall of America
that wasn't in the UFC at the mall of America outside the UFC.
Sure.
People would be like,
oh,
I wish I never did much.
I'm mushrooms was in,
was in Winnipeg,
was not at a UFC,
was just that comedy shows.
Oh,
uh,
but the UFC experience was so fun for me to give these people the drugs that I
took and I want you to experience this heavily blown out on we'd experience at
me and das get to do,
and it was fun to spread that joy.
It really was fun.
It was one of my favorite memories of this UFC one.
If you could do that again,
now that it's totally legal.
Ooh,
maybe you're right.
California and Nevada,
they're both legally legal,
legal,
Massachusetts,
legal.
Wow.
There's a bunch of states now,
you know,
and now all of Canada,
all of candidates,
October 17th Canada fucking went whole hog.
Now what if it could do it again?
Canada salute you.
Bad mother fuckers.
Finally constellations.
That's a beautiful thing they did.
They made it legal ash nationwide hour before the first guy got pulled over for
smoking weed in this car.
Probably right now.
That's what it was.
It was an hour after it was fully legalize.
The guy busted for smoking weed in the car.
Don't do that.
Well we before you get in the car,
you idiot on stupid.
Don't be ridiculous.
Yeah,
but that was when my favorite memories of UFC is having that thing.
We had some good God damn times and it was funny that it took me a long time to
figure out that I could combine the UFC and comedy.
Yeah.
I remember you taking this with us a few times and then I was like,
two,
why are we doing nothing on Friday nights?
And like,
what do you mean?
Like I can't schedule a show.
Can you schedule a show?
Yeah,
I mean we're going to do guest spot somewhere.
let's just make a couple of bucks.
What did we,
how did we start doing it?
I think we would,
I think honestly when we did like the Pearl or something court Macau and we'd be
like,
Hey,
if you want to come in and do a set,
you can like,
like dom Irrera.
He's like,
he'll come to a site.
I remember smoking cigars with me,
you,
him,
Kevin James,
and just like the common bar.
I hated those clubs,
but there's common bars were the best and we were,
we could sneak around back then
we didn't get mobbed.
And then eventually it was like,
hey,
instead of just doing an occasional guest spots,
why don't we do clubs?
And the clubs would get full.
I remember guide toward doing something maybe in Omaha and it was like,
well,
how about a midnight Friday show?
Can we do that?
You don't want to bump anybody.
Right.
But then you would schedule it months and months out.
So nobody was scheduled.
And then theaters,
it was just one night anyway.
Um,
and it was just became like,
we're not wasting time doing these fun UFC stuff.
We're actually working.
If you ever want to do those again,
man,
we could do some.
It became harder as I started headlining to be like,
I got to give up time
to go do that.
I remember one time it was a,
you were like,
can you come to Dallas?
You know how there's like shows that are important to you.
It might not be the most money or anything,
but it's important to you.
Um,
case in point,
I went in to do the Wilbur my first time doing the Wilbur,
you know,
and that was one of the ones I remember you doing the opening for you.
And then I'm doing two shows.
The Wilbur,
I'm like,
this is,
I want to show Boston's an important comedy city so that I was like,
I needed to get like a really good,
it was just somebody,
I got Joe list.
It was like,
you're a headline or I need you to open for me.
And luckily he been opened for Louis and his schedule became clear.
Um,
because lucky for us,
that's how I opened every show.
Lucky for us.
Uh,
but um,
yeah,
and you were like,
you had to show in Dallas and you're like,
can you do it?
I'm like,
I'm doing the fucking San Francisco,
um,
comedy festivals.
Like how much you can pay it.
Like honestly,
like 400 bucks.
It's not about that.
I agreed and you're like,
I'll give you $5,000.
I'll cancel now.
Let me get off the phone right now and I'll go ahead and finish.
You can't do it cause it would be more fun.
Yeah,
there's that too.
Who would you be more fun?
I mean,
we've had some fucking fun man last
and when I talked to people about the road,
the gall,
the road is lonely.
The roads.
I'm like,
you're doing it wrong.
It's supposed to do with your best friends.
Do some fun shit with it.
I try to stay later on Sunday and go hiking if it's like,
oh yeah,
if it's cold in New York and I'm an Austin,
fucking stay in the warmth a little bit and do something fun.
That's a good move,
you know?
But yeah,
but you and your friends is the number one way to turn that thing,
man.
You know,
the entourage thing,
when we did that,
it was too big.
It's too much trouble.
It's too much work.
It's too hard to organize and get everybody together.
And it was too much pressure on me.
I was like,
I don't want to deal with this.
I just want you gotta be an administrator too with all those people.
Two openers or two acts with me.
It's too much work.
One person is fine.
The only reason you brought a second opener because the one open,
it was so irresponsible.
You couldn't trust that he'd be there.
But he was so brilliant that I refused to not hire him whenever I could work
with.
The obvious answer is get someone else.
But you were like,
no,
I'll get a buffer in case.
Well,
my feeling on Diaz Zoe's like I have a special,
I've always had a special place in my heart for him because I,
he reminded me so much at my friend Johnny Johnny be from New York who taught at
the pool player.
Yeah.
And like I knew what Joey was,
he's just brilliant guy who had a really hard time with reality,
with,
with re,
with life,
with civilization.
He was just,
but in those moments of brilliance,
he was worth everything to me.
So I was like,
look,
what I'm going to try to do with this guy is I'm going to try to somehow or
another,
because I had,
I was in main stream,
I had a television show,
pull them in clubs that I could headline.
I'm like,
I'm going to bring this guy into the world and I'm going to show them how I do
it and I'm going to like indoctrinate him.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna.
You know what I mean?
He's older than me and I respect him and I'm not like a mentor to him,
but I am someone who was more advanced in comedy and but was a giant fan of Joey
Dhea.
So it was like,
I just want to figure out a way where the it can work for this guy because I
know if this guys is out there hustling and being crazy and doing coke,
it's just,
it's going to go off the rails like whatever I can do to,
and I think it helped him that someone who was established who,
Oh,
a guy who legitimately me.
It didn't give a fuck what he did.
I wanted him to be myself.
I want to be at south.
We would love to wild with the owner,
be fun.
I don't care.
I never cared about what went on.
I wanted,
I wanted fun for everybody.
Like that was,
it was important for me that I'd be the only one.
That's one of the biggest poisons ever with comics.
Be the only funny one or on the headliner.
I'm the only one who kills.
And you,
you guys are doing too well or are you guys are doing too much time for me it
was like go have fun.
We're here to party.
This is a party.
I mean I just did way too long.
It was just me and you.
I think I did 44 minutes and red bands like two do are like 45 minutes.
I was like,
no,
I did that for,
just didn't realize it.
He was like,
you did?
I'm like,
there's no way I did 25 or 30 but that's such a good club.
The comedy works and he goes,
I recorded it on video.
I can show you the starting point in the any point.
And he did and I was like,
oh fuck.
I've told you this before.
But,
but I was like,
dude,
I am so sorry.
That was way wrong.
Like,
no,
it didn't matter.
I like,
no,
I'm really,
I'm really sorry.
He goes,
no,
it didn't matter.
I'm like,
no,
but I shouldn't do that.
You're like,
no,
you killed.
And then I went up and killed.
So you haven't made a connection to me where it does actually matter.
Does we both killed?
Why is it an issue if it goes off the rails one time and you go long,
like who gives a shit?
Yeah,
that's not a consistent thing.
The whole thing to,
to all of us,
she'd be,
we know the process chart,
some shit have fun and the audience has a great time.
That's what I all,
that's all I wanted and like to have also that stand up wasn't something that I
had to do for money.
Like stand up was almost like supplementing,
whether it was news,
radio money or fear factor money.
It's like a had all this money that I,
I could,
my bills were okay.
I was okay.
I didn't have to think about it.
So I didn't worry about getting kicked out of clubs.
I didn't worry about not getting booked.
I'm like,
so what?
Like we're here to have fun and we rolled through the entire country like that
and it worked out.
It was fun.
God Damn Dude,
we had the time of our lives.
When you look back,
if we look back as you know,
senior citizens at the fucking,
the rare great times that we had consistently all across the country,
the offstage stuff was stuff great.
Uh,
for me onstage it was getting more stage time that I would get in La and I was
getting this weird exposure to an actual good crowd where I could like
experiment with pausing.
I wouldn't be afraid of losing a crowd if I shows you do and a half hour
consistently,
two shows a night.
I was talking to Michelle,
she just went to what will,
if she just went to a,
I think commerce for the first time and I was like,
oh how was it?
She goes,
it's not fair.
They're laughing at setups.
It's just too good at it doesn't make sense.
I'm like it's a victory lap.
You should enjoy it.
And then I remember like I think that might've been the first time I went with
Brogan was and I was doing so well but he's like,
oh you're coming with me again.
It was almost like,
like it was unfair showcase.
You know why I already knew you were funny.
Yeah,
that's,
that's why you asked me to go with one with first place,
but like,
but I was like,
this is the perfect club for anybody to try out in.
Cause it's so sad.
It's like a wind assisted a hundred yard dash,
you know,
with heavy gusts of wind.
Right.
It's almost like you have a sale.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
they were fun.
Yeah.
We had a great fucking time dude.
But at,
and it works.
Look,
I mean,
look how all the people that went with us,
whether it's Diaz or Dunkin or you or Segura,
they're murdering now all over the country,
murdering,
doing quite well.
If I was a talent scout dude,
I'd be 100% no,
you would not think harder.
Okay.
It's not because I was going to write down a name,
but you're not.
You're not.
You're not 100% got him clothes.
Do you have a great percentage of the people that I wasn't 100% on,
they failed themselves.
They had the potential of the bay
and then it's on them.
Well,
discipline is something that a lot of people lack,
man.
And it's not very,
very unfortunate.
And we're seeing it right now.
Bert.
Kreischer you're behind by a thousand points.
Motherfucker.
Can I promote two days before we go?
I'm doing a lot of reading of the,
of a,
um,
with the indigent O'Neil in New York.
November 11th of the screenplay I wrote in college.
Oh,
I've been hearing about this and Oh,
by the way,
it's horrible podcast on sober October when you're walking around New York.
It's God damn awesome.
I'm so angry and full of fucking withdrawal.
My,
you're my favorite when you're angry.
Angry.
Ari's my favorite.
All right.
When you still fuck it.
That's,
that's my favorite Aria.
And then I got a European door coming November and uh,
and uh,
November 16 starts in Reykjavik and it ends November,
December 9th.
Then Zurich can all sorts of cities.
So please already the great.com for tickets.
Um,
I love to see out there Brussels,
I'm Sadam Copenhagen,
all sorts of places.
Boom.
There's 10 more days,
ladies and gentlemen,
as head more days and then grew that hair on 10 more days and then we're going
crazy.
I can't wait until then.
We'll be the wrap up show where someone besides Bert Kreischer.
We'll get that championship belt.
I might go workout right now.
I'm gonna go work out right now.
I have to twist the blade.
All right.
Bye Buddy.